This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. When your schedule is packed with work projects, home projects, managing kid activities, I don't know, friends, big occasions, sometimes you feel like you cannot carve out time for yourself. Even when we know what makes us happy, it's hard to make time for it. But when you feel like you have no time for yourself, non-negotiables like therapy are more important than ever. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give Better Help a try. It's entirely online, it's designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. You fill out a questionnaire online, you get matched
本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助播出。当你的日程排满了工作项目、家庭项目、照顾孩子的活动、还有什么呢，朋友们、盛大的活动时，有时你会觉得自己根本无法抽出时间留给自己。即使我们知道什么能让自己快乐，也很难为此腾出时间。但当你觉得没有时间留给自己时，像心理治疗这样不可妥协的事情就比以往任何时候都重要。如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试 BetterHelp。它完全在网上进行，旨在提供便利、灵活的服务，并适合你的日程安排。你在网上填写一份问卷，就能匹配到
with a licensed therapist, and you can switch therapists at any time and there is no additional charge. Take that time for yourself. Never skip therapy day with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp.help.com slash ladies. Own each step with Peloton. From their pop runs to walk and talks, you define what it means to be a runner. Whatever your level, embrace it. Journey starts when you say so. If you've got five minutes or 50,
一位持证心理治疗师，而且你可以随时更换治疗师，不收取任何额外费用。为自己留出这段时间。绝不错过 BetterHelp 的心理治疗日。今天就访问 betterhelp.com 斜杠 ladies，首月即可享受九折优惠。网址是 betterhelp.com 斜杠 ladies。用 Peloton 开启每一步。从跑步机跑步到边走边聊，你来定义什么是跑步者。无论你的水平如何，去拥抱它。旅程从你开口的那一刻开始。如果你有五分钟或五十分钟，
Peloton Tread has workouts you can work in. Or bring your classes with you for outdoor runs, walks and hikes led by expert instructors on the Peloton app. Call yourself a runner. Peloton all-access membership separate. Learn more at onepeloton.ca slash running. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together.
Peloton 跑步机上有适合你的锻炼项目。或者在 Peloton 应用上，由专家教练带领，带着你的课程进行户外跑步、步行和徒步。称自己为跑步者吧。Peloton 全面访问会员资格另计。了解更多信息请访问 onepeloton.ca 斜杠 running。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch Podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello! Hey there. Oh my goodness.
我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。你好！嗨。哦天哪。
We are sitting in such a cool space. This is our brand new recording studio thanks to Odyssey. It's so fancy. It has natural light. We've never had a recording space. We've never had a window with windows to the outside world. I can see the sky and I'm talking to you. This is crazy. We're not in a box. Do you know what though? Remember on the office when Randall Einhorn told us that if like a character had something like a future that they were going toward. You're pulling out the window in the conference room?
我们正坐在一个这么酷的空间里。多亏了 Odyssey，这是我们的全新录音室。太高档了。这里有自然光。我们以前从来没有过录音室。我们以前从来没有过一扇朝向外部世界的窗户。我能看到天空，而且我在跟你说话。这太疯狂了。我们不在盒子里。不过你知道吗？还记得在《办公室》里，兰德尔·埃因霍恩告诉我们，如果某个角色有一个他们正在迈向的未来……你正在拉开会议室里的窗户吗？
Oh, Jenna. Cause they would be by a window. We have a future. Yeah, we're moving kind of in a new direction soon. Yeah and we're looking out. We're looking out at our future. Like Jim and Pam. Yes! It's all happening. Did you know you were gonna bring that up? No it occurred to me just now. You know guys I love it when the office just creeps right into your real life. All the time. All the time.
哦，珍娜。因为他们会在窗户旁边。我们有一个未来。对，我们很快就要朝着一个新方向前进了。对，我们在向外看。我们正展望着我们的未来。就像吉姆和帕姆。没错！这一切都在发生。你知道你要提起这个吗？不知道，我刚才突然想到的。你知道吗，伙计们，我就是喜欢《办公室》直接渗透进你们现实生活中的这种感觉。一直都是。一直都是。
All right, well, today we are talking about promos. It is season 9, episode 19, written by Tim McAuliffe and directed by Jen Salata. And Jen sent in some really great audio clips. Jen is the best. I mean, I know we've said this before, but I love it whenever she talks about an episode she directed, and you guys are going to enjoy these clips.
好的，那么今天我们要谈论的是宣传片。这是第九季第十九集，由蒂姆·麦考利夫编剧，珍·萨拉塔执导。珍发来了一些非常棒的音频剪辑。珍是最好的。我是说，我知道我们以前说过这个，但我就是喜欢每当她谈起她导演的一集时，你们大家一定会喜欢这些剪辑。
Well, to kick things off, here is your summary. The documentary promo is officially out, and everyone is very excited at first. At first. Soon, they realize that they have been being filmed more often than they thought. And all the nooks and crannies they thought they were hidden. Dwight's new relationship with Esther sparks jealousy in Angela. Clark is convinced that Esther is only dating Dwight so her dad can get a tractor. Oscar and Angela have to confess a few things to the senator.
好了，为了拉开序幕，以下是你的剧情概要。纪录片宣传片正式发布了，一开始大家都非常兴奋。一开始。很快，他们意识到自己被拍摄的频率比想象的要高。他们以为自己藏起来的所有犄角旮旯都被拍到了。德怀特与埃丝特的新恋情引发了安吉拉的嫉妒。克拉克确信埃丝特和德怀特约会只是为了让她爸爸能得到一台拖拉机。奥斯卡和安吉拉不得不向参议员坦白一些事情。
And Pam visits with Brian the boom guy. Oh boy. I've got a lot to say about that. Meanwhile, Jim and Daryl's meeting with MLB player Ryan Howard gets awkward. Well that leads me very well into fast fact number one, guest star Ryan Howard. Yeah. All right. His nickname is the big, and he was the first baseman for the Philadelphia Phillies from 2004 to 2016. So he was the current first baseman for the Phillies and a World Series champion when he shot this episode. Crazy.
还有帕姆去拜访了 boom 杆收音师布赖恩。哦天哪。关于这个我有很多话要说。与此同时，吉姆和达里尔与美国职棒大联盟球员莱恩·霍华德的会面变得很尴尬。这非常顺理成章地引出了我们的趣味事实一，客串明星莱恩·霍华德。没错。好的。他的绰号是“大个子”，他从 2004 年到 2016 年效力于费城费城人队，担任一垒手。所以他拍摄这一集时，正是费城人队的现役一垒手兼世界大赛冠军。太疯狂了。
Crazy. Steve Burgess said everybody enjoyed having him on set. He was fantastic. And Jen Salata said the same thing. Let's listen. It was such a treat having Ryan Howard in the office. I am not a huge baseball fan, but I definitely knew who he was.
太疯狂了。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说大家都很高兴他在片场。他太棒了。珍·萨拉塔也说了同样的话。我们来听听。莱恩·霍华德来到《办公室》客串，真是一大幸事。我不是一个超级棒球迷，但我绝对知道他是谁。
And people were telling me his stats leading up to the filming. And he just, it was fun. It was fun to have him around. I thought he did such a good job. John and Craig were really excited to have him on set. And they made him feel really welcome. And it seemed like he was such a good job. John and Craig were really excited to have him on set and they made him feel really welcome and it seemed like he was having a fun time. Well, let me tell you something.
人们在拍摄前一直在告诉我他的数据。他真的很棒。有他在身边很有趣。我觉得他做得太棒了。约翰和克拉克非常高兴他能来到片场。他们让他感到非常受欢迎。看起来他做得太棒了。约翰和克拉克非常高兴他能来到片场，他们让他感到非常受欢迎，而且看起来他玩得很开心。好吧，我来告诉你们一件事。
I did something crazy. I know what you're talking about. I slid into Ryan Howard's DM on Instagram. You told me you were going to and I was like, okay. Well. Every time we do that with someone that we don't know as well, I'm always like, whoa. I know, well, we didn't have any scenes with him.
我做了一件疯狂的事。我知道你在说哪件。我在 Instagram 上私信了莱恩·霍华德。你告诉过我说你要去发，而我的反应是，好吧。好吧。每次我们对不太熟悉的人做出这种举动时，我总是会想，哇。我知道，不过，我们没有和他的对手戏。
We didn't. So I was like, well, it's worth a shot. By the way, he is from my hometown of St. Louis, Missouri. So I tried to pull out some good Emos pizza toasted ravioli references in my DM to butter him up. And guess what? He is just as you suspected the nicest guy he wrote me back and he sent in audio clips about his time on the office on the set he's
我们没有。所以我当时就想，好吧，值得一试。顺便说一句，他是我的家乡密苏里州圣路易斯人。所以我试图在我的私信里搬出一些好的埃莫斯比萨、烤意式饺子之类的梗来讨好他。你猜怎么着？他正如你所猜测的那样，是最好的人。他回信了，他还发来了关于他在《办公室》片场度过的那段时光的音频剪辑，他真是
wonderful wonderful so the first thing we asked was what was it like shooting the office from his perspective and here's what he had to say Jenna Angela thank you guys so so much love what you guys are doing with the podcast. I'm glad that I can Have an opportunity to partake. So Question one was how was my experience shooting the office? Absolutely amazing the cast everyone John and Craig were outstanding. Everybody made it so fluid and so easy for me They just told me to just be myself,
太棒了太棒了。所以我们问的第一个问题是：从他的角度来看，拍摄《办公室》是什么体验？他是这样说的：珍娜，安吉拉，非常非常感谢你们。太喜欢你们用播客做的事情了。我很高兴能有机会参与其中。所以第一个问题是：我拍摄《办公室》的经历是怎样的？绝对是惊艳的。演员阵容，每个人，约翰和克拉克都太出色了。每个人都让这一切变得如此流畅，对我来说太轻松了。他们只是告诉我做我自己，
just relax and have fun and just made it very, very loose and easy for me to be able to enjoy myself doing it. So really, really made it seamless and I really had fun doing it. Loved every moment of it. All right, so then I had to ask him, was he a fan of the show when he got the job? And here's what he had to say.
只需放松并享受乐趣，这让我的整个过程变得非常非常轻松自然，让我能够享受其中。所以真的，真的让一切变得天衣无缝，我真的很享受这个过程。喜欢其中的每一个时刻。好的，然后我不得不问他，当他得到这份工作时，他是该剧的粉丝吗？他是这样说的：
You know, to start, I never, I heard a little bit about it at the time I was in AAA, which took place in Scranton. And a couple of people had actually come up to me and told me about the show and that there was a character named Ryan Howard on the show. So I never really knew about it at the start. And I was like, oh man, that seems really cool. And then, you know, kind of fast forward,
你知道，一开始，我从没……当时我在 3A 级联赛时听说过一点，那个联赛在斯克兰顿举行。确实有几个人走过来跟我提起过这部剧，说剧里有一个叫莱恩·霍华德的角色。所以我一开始其实并不了解它。当时我就想，哦天哪，这看起来太酷了。然后呢，你知道的，随着我的职业生涯不断推进，
you know, through my career and the opportunity to be able to get on the show, ultimately became a fan, the more I started to learn more about the show and be able to watch the show. And so having the opportunity to hop on there was something that was really, really cool and unique. The way that I came about it was, you know, my agent at the time, I guess, you know, had
以及能够参演这部剧的机会到来，随着我对这部剧了解得越来越多，并且开始观看这部剧，我最终成为了它的粉丝。所以有机会加入其中，是一件非常非常酷且独特的事情。我得到这个机会的途径是，你知道的，我当时的经纪人，我猜，你知道的，
some connections over there. And obviously with the character of Ryan Howard on the show and myself, I think it only made sense. It really only made sense to do it. And like I said, for me, it was something that's outside of my usual comfort zone and wanted to kind of challenge myself. And like I said before, just absolutely loved every bit of it and being able to be a part of the show.
在那边有一些人脉。显然，考虑到剧里有莱恩·霍华德这个角色，而我本人也叫莱恩·霍华德，我觉得这再合情合理不过了。这样做真的再顺理成章不过了。就像我说的，对我来说，这超出了我通常的舒适区，我想挑战一下自己。就像我之前说的，绝对喜欢其中的每一分每一秒，并且能够成为这部剧的一部分。
I cannot believe he said it was outside of his comfort zone. He looked like such a natural. I agree. I was going to say the same thing. And the first time when he was like, hi, nice to meet you, eat fresh. I know. I was like to say the same thing. And the first time when he was like, Hi, nice to meet you. Eat fresh. I know. I was like, this guy is hilarious.
我简直不敢相信他说这超出了他的舒适区。他看起来太自然了。我同意。我正想这么说。第一次当他说“嗨，很高兴见到你，吃得新鲜”时。我知道。我当时就想：我正想这么说。而第一次当他说“嗨，很高兴见到你。吃得新鲜”时。我知道。我当时就想，这家伙太搞笑了。
All right. Well, fast fact number two, and is we had another guest star in this episode and it was Subway. Yeah, we did. Like you said, Ryan Howard keeps saying the Subway catchphrase, eat fresh in this episode. Well, Steve Burgess said that this was one of the ways that we got Ryan Howard on the show. That Subway had been trying to get some sort of product placement or integration into the office.
好的。那么，趣味事实二，我们在这一集里还有另一个客串明星，那就是赛百味。是的，确实有。正如你所说，莱恩·霍华德在这集里一直在说赛百味的广告词“吃得新鲜”。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，这是我们让莱恩·霍华德参演这部剧的方式之一。赛百味当时一直试图在《办公室》中进行某种产品植入或整合。
Ryan Howard was already their spokesperson at the time, so this kind of worked out perfectly. A lot of the times, Greg was pretty opposed to any kind of product placement deals, but since this fit our storyline, he approved it. It totally worked. And Steve Burgess did say that we had to have Subway representatives on set to supervise. This is one of the reasons why it's not fun
莱恩·霍华德当时已经是他们的代言人了，所以这算是一拍即合。很多时候，格雷ッグ非常反对任何形式的产品植入协议，但既然这符合我们的剧情，他就批准了。效果完全恰到好处。史蒂夫·伯吉斯确实说过，我们必须让赛百味代表在片场监督。这就是为什么拥有产品植入一点也不好玩的原因之一，
to have product placement, because the star of the commercial is the product. It's not the star of the reasons why it's not fun to have product placement. Because the star of the commercial is the product. It's not the star of the commercial. I will never forget when we were doing our Chili's commercial together. There was a tray of appetizers. And that tray of appetizers sitting in front of us got its own lighting. Yeah, it had its own person. Like making sure it looked good on camera.
因为广告的主角是产品。它不是广告的主角。原因之一就是拥有产品植入并不好玩。因为广告的主角是产品。它不是广告的主角。我永远不会忘记我们一起拍气滋林（Chili's）广告的时候。当时有一盘开胃菜。摆在我们面前的那盘开胃菜甚至有它专属的打光。对，它有专人负责。就像确保它在镜头前看起来很好一样。
Yeah, and if you do a take and it's like super funny, but they don't like how the light was hitting the chicken popper, you have to do it again. Right. So that's why we would not really want to have to have like some product in an episode, but this worked great because Subway got in the episode through Ryan Howard, through the catchphrase. Steve said the Subway people were very laid back, they were happy with everything, and this actually turned into a multi-episode deal with Subway. We should be on the
对，如果你拍了一条，效果超级搞笑，但他们不喜欢光打在鸡米花上的效果，你就得重拍。没错。所以这就是为什么我们其实不太希望在一集里植入某种产品，但这次效果很棒，因为赛百味通过莱恩·霍华德、通过这句广告词植入了这一集。史蒂夫说赛百味的人非常随和，他们对一切都很满意，这实际上演变成了与赛百味的多次合作协议。我们得
lookout. Steve Burgess says you're gonna see Subway stuff in the background of a few scenes in some upcoming episodes. No way. Track it. I did not know that. Me either. Well, now it's time for my favorite thing. It's when Angela takes fast fact number three. I understand you've got a DVD update for us today. I sure do. You all that have the box set,
拭目以待。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，在接下来几集的几个场景的背景里，你会看到赛百味的东西。不会吧。找找看。我竟然不知道。我也不知道。好吧，现在是我最喜欢的环节了。安吉拉带来趣味事实三。我听说你今天要给我们带来 DVD 的更新。我当然有。所有拥有套装的各位，
we are on disc four of season nine. It's the second to last disc. Ah, I have feelings about it. Here are the episodes and the features on this disc. The episodes are promos, Stare-Mageddon, Paper Airplane, and Live in the Dream. And the bonus features are deleted scenes and, quote, a look back, the cast farewells. Oh, I remember when we did those. Yeah, we all say our goodbyes to the show while we're filming the last episode. John talked about that in his interview
我们目前在第九季第四张碟。这是倒数第二张碟。啊，我对它很有感觉。这张碟上的剧集和花絮有这些。剧集是《宣传片》、《凝视末日》、《纸飞机》和《活在梦中》。而花絮则是删减片段以及“回顾：演员告别”。哦，我记得我们录制那个时候。是的，我们在拍摄最后一集时，都向这部剧做了最后的告别。约翰在采访中谈到了这一点，
because he was the one who really spearheaded that. He wanted to document that. Well, I was crying as I watched them all. It just, oh, man, I want to share some of it when we get to the finale. Please do. It's really, oh, it's emotional. Well, listen when we get to the finale. Please do. It's really, oh, it's emotional. Well listen lady, that's all I've got.
因为他是真正带头做这件事的人。他想把这一切记录下来。好吧，我在看大家录制的这些时哭了。真的，哦，天哪，等我们讲到大结局时，我想分享其中的一部分。请务必分享。真的，哦，太感人了。好吧，听着，伙计，这就是我所有的内容了。
Should we take a break and then when we get back, we start breaking down this episode? Yes, before we take a break, I just have to share with you guys, you know I'm like a visual person, which is hilarious that I podcast. But the room we're in is so nice. Odyssey has set us up, so lovely.
我们该休息一下，回来后就开始剖析这一集吗？好的，在休息之前，我必须跟你们分享一件事，你知道我是一个很注重视觉效果的人——尽管我去录播客这件事本身就很搞笑。但我们所在的这个房间太棒了。Odyssey 把我们安排得这么好、这么可爱。
Our table has an outlet in the middle. I could charge my phone if I needed to. Yeah. And there's no shower curtain between us and Sam and Cassie. There's a wall with a window. We can see them. We can see them. Again.
我们的桌子中间有一个电源插座。如果需要的话，我可以给手机充电。是的。而且我们和萨姆、凯西之间没有浴帘。有一堵带窗户的墙。我们可以看到他们。我们可以看到他们。再次强调。
Anyway, this is so nice. I wanna give a video tour of where we are now. Definitely go to our Instagram, Office Ladies Pod. Angela's going to give you a visual documentation. I need you to see where we are because it's so flippin' nice. OK, now we can go to break. MUSIC Well, this episode starts with Phyllis at her desk. She's got headphones in and she is listening to something that's making her really happy.
不管怎样，这太好了。我想录个视频带大家参观一下我们现在所在的地方。一定要去我们的 Instagram，Office Ladies Pod。安吉拉会为你提供视觉记录。我需要让你们看看我们现在在哪儿，因为这里实在是太棒了。好了，现在我们可以去休息了。音乐：好吧，这一集开始于菲利斯坐在她的办公桌前。她戴着耳机，正在听让她非常快乐的东西。
She's kind of rocking back and forth in her chair. Kevin announces she's doing it again. Yes. Then we cut to a talking head between Pam and Clark. Pam and Clark. Pam and Clark. Did you notice it as well? Yes. I want you to know, I went to the shooting draft
她在椅子里前后摇晃着。凯文宣布她又开始了。是的。然后镜头切到帕姆和克拉克的单人访谈。帕姆和克拉克。帕姆和克拉克。你也注意到了吗？是的。我想让你们知道，我查阅了拍摄初稿，
because I was very curious about this combination of talking head. And later in the script, Clark talks a little bit about Pam. And I'm going to share it. But I wonder if there was a little bit more of a theme of seeing how the two of them are desk mates. Well, the idea was to draw attention to the fact that Jim is not there. Yes.
因为我对这种单人访谈的组合非常好奇。在剧本的后面部分，克拉克谈到了帕姆。我会分享出来的。但我很好奇，这其中是不是还有更深一点的主题，就是看看他们两个作为同桌的相处。嗯，这个想法是为了吸引人们注意吉姆不在的事实。是的。
That having Pam alone wouldn't have the same effect as having her paired with someone. So that was the idea behind this Pam-Clark pairing. Yes. And you're going to see them interact more in this episode than you ever have. As I read the shooting draft again and saw the other moments that didn't make it into the episode between Pam and Clark, it really just made me realize how creative our writers were at planting these subtle themes of Pam missing Jim and Jim's absence, her partner being gone.
让帕姆独自一人不会产生和她与某人搭档时一样的效果。所以这就是这个“帕姆-克拉克”组合背后的想法。是的。你会看到他们在这一集里的互动比以往任何时候都要多。当我再次阅读拍摄初稿，看到帕姆和克拉克之间那些没有被剪进正片的其他时刻时，它真的让我意识到我们的编剧在埋下这些微妙主题时是多么有创意：帕姆想念吉姆、吉姆的缺席、她的搭档不在了。
Yeah, well, Pam and Clark are gonna explain that Phyllis has gotten into audiobooks and she's currently listening to 50 Shades of Grey, which is porn. That's what Clark says. Yeah, exactly. And I guess as Phyllis is kind of rocking back and forth, she's scooching over towards Dwight's desk area
对，好吧，帕姆和克拉克会解释说菲利斯迷上了有声书，她目前正在听《五十度灰》，那是色情作品。克拉克是这么说的。对，没错。而且我猜当菲利斯前后摇晃时，她一直在朝德怀特的办公桌区域挪动，
and she's hitting the back of his chair in the process and the whole bullpen has had it. Yeah everyone marches in to Andy's office to complain but Toby says that Phyllis is not technically in violation of any I guess rules of the office unless she acts on her feelings of being aroused. If she's just being aroused it's okay. Yeah this gets a collective moan. I want you guys to know, this scene was a historic moment on the set of The Office because Oscar Nunez only broke twice on camera, like really broke. And this was the second time it made it into the
在这个过程中她撞到了他的椅子背，整个开放式办公区的人都忍无可忍了。是的，每个人都气势汹汹地走进安迪的办公室抱怨，但托比说菲利斯在技术上没有违反办公室的任何……我猜是规则，除非她对被挑逗的感觉付诸行动。如果她只是在被挑逗，那是可以的。是的，这引来了一阵集体哀叹。我想让你们知道，这个场景是《办公室》片场的一个历史性时刻，因为奥斯卡·努涅斯在镜头前只笑场了两次——我是说真正意义上的笑场。这是第二次被收录进
bloopers. I want you to hear it. It's a complete exaggeration. Phyllis is not masturbating. She's just in an extreme state. Oscar broke! Oscar broke! Cause he, cause he broke! Cause he, cause he broke! Cause he, cause he broke! Cause rain went down!
NG花絮里。我想让你们听听。这完全是夸大其词。菲利斯根本没有自慰。她只是处于一种极端的状态。奥斯卡笑场了！奥斯卡笑场了！因为他，因为他笑场了！因为他，因为他笑场了！因为他，因为他笑场了！因为雨水落下来了！
Like two times in nine years! Thank God! Broke! We all lost it! It's so funny because there is a scene that Oscar is in in this episode that I would have predicted is the one that he broke in. Nope. It's coming up later. It was this one. Wow.
九年里大概就两次！谢天谢地！笑场了！我们所有人都崩溃了！太搞笑了，因为奥斯卡在这一集里有一个场景，我本来以为他会在这场戏里笑场。结果并没有。稍后就会播到。就是这场。哇。
Well, Dwight is going to have to take matters into his own hands, and that means he's going to dump a bucket of water onto Phyllis' head. Poor Phyllis. I know. Andy takes her phone and says she can have it back at the end of the day, but then he goes in his office and listens to the audio book. And then he starts kind of rocking back and forth.
好吧，德怀特不得不亲自采取行动，这意味着他要往菲利斯的头上倒一桶水。可怜的菲利斯。我知道。安迪拿走了她的手机，说她可以在一天结束时拿回手机，但他随后走进办公室，听起了那本有声书。然后他开始前后摇晃。
And then Andy gets pummeled with water. Mm-hmm. Well, you guys might remember when we interviewed Phyllis, it's a fantastic interview. If you haven't heard it, go listen to it. But we had to ask her about this scene, and she had a lot to say about it. Yes, she mentioned that there was a take where Rain basically like almost drowned her in water because they did more than one. Yeah, and I guess on one particular take she wasn't really thinking and she left her mouth
接着安迪也被兜头浇了一盆水。嗯哼。好吧，大家可能还记得我们采访菲利斯的时候，那是一场非常精彩的采访。如果你还没听过，赶紧去听听。但我们不得不问她关于这场戏的事情，她有很多话要说。对，她提到过有一个镜头里，雷恩基本上用水把她给“淹”了，因为他们拍了不止一次。是的，我猜在其中某次特定拍摄中她没过脑子，把嘴张得
wide open and she like swallowed all this water. Well our director Jen Salata remembered this moment too and here's what she had to say about it. All I remembered about the Phyllis getting water dumped on her is that there was one take with an enormous amount of water and I actually got to rewatch that take because I reached out to Dave Rogers, our editor extraordinaire, and he showed me a couple of the takes. And the one where Rain just dumped water, I think it was the first take on Phyllis,
大大的，结果把这些水全吞下去了。好吧，我们的导演珍·萨拉塔也记得这个时刻，以下是她对此的说法：关于菲利斯被倒水这件事，我记得的全部就是，有一个镜头的水量极大，我实际上有机会重新观看那个镜头，因为我联系了我们卓越的剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯，他给我看了几个不同的镜头。而在雷恩直接倒水的那个镜头里，我想那是拍菲利斯的第一个镜头，
she was such a pro, she was trying to keep going and say her line, but she was coughing and she was laughing, and she was putting her hand up to try to disguise the fact that she was laughing because she really wanted to keep going. But I ended up calling cut after we got through a version of the scene with some coughs and some covered laughs. And you could hear Ed, as soon as I yelled cut, say like, Jesus Dwight, you waterboarded her.
她真是个专业演员，她一直在试图坚持下去并说出台词，但她又咳嗽又笑，她还把手抬起来试图掩盖她在笑的事实，因为她真的很想坚持演下去。但我最终在拍完一个带有咳嗽声和掩饰性笑声的版本后喊了“卡”。你甚至能听到埃德在我喊完“卡”之后立刻说：“天哪，德怀特，你对她实施水刑了。”
So we ended up doing another take of the scene. After lunch, Phyllis was dry and her hair and wardrobe were dry, so we had another go at it. And it ended up being really funny. Oh my gosh, well, like Jen said, they had to do several takes of Phyllis and also Ed getting water thrown on them.
所以我们最后又重拍了一场戏。午饭后，菲利斯干了，她的头发和服装也干了，于是我们又拍了一遍。最后效果非常搞笑。哦天哪，好吧，正如珍所说，他们不得不拍好几条菲利斯以及埃德被泼水的镜头。
And this requires some really special scheduling for production. I bet, because then they have to reset. They have to get new clothes. They have to blow dry their hair. So the way Steve Burgess scheduled this, like Jen mentioned, was we did Phyllis, we doused her with water, and then we had a lunch break.
这需要制片组进行非常特殊的排期。我敢说，因为接着他们必须重新准备。他们得换新衣服。他们得用吹风机吹干头发。所以史蒂夫·伯吉斯安排这个的方式是，正如珍所提到的，我们先拍菲利斯，把水泼在她身上，然后我们吃午饭。
So she could get dry and ready again, and we would dump water on her again after lunch. But the other thing that they did was they set up the conference room to shoot talking heads. So while those guys were resetting, we would just pop in and do a few talking heads. So there was no downtime. Yeah, no time was wasted. You can't waste any time on a shooting day.
这样她就能变干并重新准备好，午饭后我们会再次往她身上倒水。但他们做的另一件事是，他们把会议室布置好用来拍单人访谈。所以当那些人重新准备时，我们就顺便进去拍几个单人访谈。这样就没有停工时间了。是的，没有浪费任何时间。在拍摄日里，你不能浪费任何时间。
And also since you don't see the person dumping water on Andy, I mean, it's meant to be Dwight. Yeah, you just see hands, but they could be any man hands. We used a crew member for that. Because then Rain could be doing other stuff too. I don't know, I find that- I was gonna say, you're just glowing right now
而且，既然你看不到向安迪倒水的人——我的意思是，本意应该是德怀特。是的，你只看到几只手，但那可以是任何男人的手。我们为此用了一个剧组成员。因为这样雷恩也可以去干别的事。我不知道，我发现——我正想说，你现在整个人都在发光，
because you're like thinking of how they had to time management and make the best use of this water gag and how else could they work and set up other sets, like I just see your brain. It's like so happy right now. Because I know that when they first started shooting things, movies, TV shows or whatever, if there was this water gag.
因为你在思考他们是如何管理时间并充分利用这个泼水梗的，以及他们还能如何工作并搭建其他布景，我简直能看到你的大脑。此刻它看起来太开心了。因为我知道，当他们刚开始拍摄电影、电视剧或者其他什么东西时，如果出现了这个泼水梗。
I know that there was a first AD that had the idea for the first time to be like, wait, I bet we could shoot something while that person's drying off. Yeah. And it just revolutionized the AD structure. And I'd love to know who it was. This is your next job. You're going to be documenting the first director history in cinema. I might. All right. Well, we've got our credits, and now we're going to get into the meat of this
我知道曾有一个第一副导演第一次想出了这个主意，他说：“等等，我打赌我们可以在那个人擦干身体的同时拍点别的。”是的。这彻底革新了副导演的架构。我很想知道那是谁。这是你的下一个工作。你要去记录电影史上第一位副导演的历史。我可能会的。好吧，我们已经播完了演职员表，现在我们要进入这一集的核心内容了。
episode. It opens with Dwight asking Clark for some dating advice. Yeah. And Angela is sort of hovering over Dwight's shoulder. She's doing some business at Phyllis' desk, and she's eavesdropping. She is. The script actually said you were listening with interest, which I thought you played perfectly.
开场是德怀特向克拉克征求一些约会建议。是的。安吉拉有点在德怀特的肩膀上方徘徊。她在菲利斯的桌子旁做点事情，然后她顺便偷听。她是。剧本里其实写着你“饶有兴致地听着”，我觉得你演得完美极了。
Clark is going to ask Dwight who he's dating, and Dwight says Esther Brueger. Angela, when he says Esther, your face is amazing. I checked the script and here was your direction. It says, quote, Angela looks to camera, ugly name. I had so much fun in this episode. I mean, this was just one of the moments I enjoyed, but this episode was a mean, this was just one of the moments I enjoyed, but this episode
克拉克要问德怀特他在和谁约会，德怀特说埃丝特·布鲁格。安吉拉，当他说出埃丝特这个名字时，你的表情太棒了。我查了剧本，上面给你的指导是这样的。上面写着：“引文：安吉拉看着镜头，丑陋的名字。”这一集我拍得太开心了。我是说，这只是我喜欢的时刻之一，但这一集对我的角色来说简直太棒了，
was a blast for my character. And yeah, Angela's already making assumptions about Esther. And Clark is trying to get more information from Dwight. He finds out that Esther has like a neighboring farm, 85 acres. Clark's like, oh yeah, keep talking. Dwight says, we've been out three times and there has been physicality. Now in the script, there were two candy bag alts for this moment that they shot, they didn't air, but I wanted to share them with you.
简直是个狂欢。而且，是的，安吉拉已经开始对埃丝特妄加揣测了。克拉克试图从德怀特那里获取更多信息。他发现埃丝特有一座相邻的农场，有 85 英亩。克拉克的反应是：哦，真的吗，继续说。德怀特说：“我们已经出去过三次了，而且有身体接触。”现在在剧本里，这个时刻有两个备选的“糖果袋”台词，他们拍了，但没有播出来，不过我想和你们分享。
When Dwight says there's been physicality, Clark says, tickle fight. Dwight says, sort of. Here's the second candy bag alt. Dwight says, we've been out three times, there's been physicality on both sides. Clark says, front and back? That's funny.
当德怀特说有身体接触时，克拉克说：“胳肢大战？”德怀特说：“算是吧。”这是第二个备选的糖果袋台词。德怀特说：“我们已经出去过三次了，双方都有身体接触。”克拉克说：“前面还是后面？”这太搞笑了。
I know. And then the scene would have continued. Yeah, Dwight explains that Esther's father wants him to enter into a tractor lease. A long-term tractor lease. But he's afraid that's gonna put pressure on the relationship. Yeah, Clark's like, wow, you know one of my buddies is going through the same thing right now.
我知道。然后场景本该继续。是的，德怀特解释说埃丝特父亲想让他签一份拖拉机租赁合同。长期的拖拉机租赁合同。但他害怕这会给这段关系带来压力。是的，克拉克的反应是：哇，你知道我的一个哥们现在也正经历同样的事。
Something's in the air. Yeah. Well, there would have been a Clark talking head that would have come right after this. I just loved it. I'm going to read you what was in the shooting draft and the candy bag alt. He would have said this. I actually enjoy talking to Dwight about dating. It's either that or ask Pam if I can bring her anything back from the kitchen. It's always tea. I weirdly remember that. And here was one of his candy bag alts. I actually enjoyed talking to Dwight about dating. It's either that or talk to Pam about what kind of plastics is safe for her kids to drink from.
有什么东西在空气中弥漫。是的。好吧，本来在这一段之后会有一个克拉克的单人访谈。我太喜欢了。我来给你们读一下拍摄初稿和糖果袋备选台词里的内容。他本会这么说：“我其实很喜欢和德怀特聊约会的事。要不就是问帕姆能不能从厨房帮我带点什么回来。总是茶。”我竟然诡异地记得这个。以下是他的其中一个糖果袋备选台词：“我其实很喜欢和德怀特聊约会的事。要不就是跟帕姆聊聊究竟哪种塑料对她的孩子饮水是安全的。
Trick question. It's none. Well, Angela does have a talking head that's in the episode, and she's very condescending toward this new relationship. She's like, oh, Dwight is dating a Brussels sprout farmer named Esther. She explained she's coming into the office today with her father.
这是个陷阱题。答案是哪种都不安全。”好吧，安吉拉确实有一个被播出的单人访谈，她在访谈中对这段新恋情表现得非常居高临下。她说：“哦，德怀特正在和一个叫埃丝特的抱子甘蓝农民约会。”她解释说她今天会和她父亲一起去办公室。
The whole thing is just Angela cannot wait to gloat about how inferior this woman is. Yeah, well, if anyone is tracking how many times Angela laughs in the entire run of the show, add this one to the list. This is a big hearty laugh at the end of her talking head. Actually, if anyone is out there tracking, I'd love to know how many times Angela
整件事就是安吉拉迫不及待地想要幸灾乐祸，嘲笑这个女人有多么逊色。是的，好吧，如果有人在统计安吉拉在整部剧集里一共笑过多少次，把这个也加到名单里。这是她在单人访谈结尾发出的一个爽朗的大笑。事实上，如果有人在外面统计的话，我很想知道安吉拉在整部剧里到底笑过多少次。
actually laughs in the entire run. If anyone is, I mean, surely Dr. Thibodeau will get on that. Dr. Thibodeau? How many times does Angela laugh? I'm gonna guess 11. Is that too many? I think it might be a few more. Okay. I do. I think she laughs on average three to four times per season. I think that's too much. Oh. Well, maybe I'm thinking of smiles.
如果有人在统计的话——我是说，蒂博多博士肯定会去研究这个的。蒂博多博士？安吉拉笑了多少次？我猜 11 次。是不是太多了？我觉得可能会再多一点。真的吗？我觉得她平均每季笑三到四次。我觉得这太多了。哦。好吧，也许我想的是微笑。
Those don't count, right? Has to be an actual laugh. An actual like, goof-a. Oh. Then maybe you're right. I think you could title this next scene Awkward in the Bullpen. Oh, this phone call's so cringy and so real.
那些不算，对吧？必须是真正的笑。真正那种“咯咯”的笑。哦。那也许你是对的。我觉得你可以把下一个场景命名为“开放式办公区的尴尬”。哦，这个电话太让人脚趾抠地了，而且太真实了。
So sad. It's between Pam and Jim, and they're just trying so hard to have a lighthearted conversation. And you can imagine that this conversation where Pam is like, oh, Cece started calling me Pamela. You know, watch out, she might start calling you Jim. Ha ha ha ha. And then they have nothing else to say.
太悲伤了。这是帕姆和吉姆之间的通话，他们只是在拼命尝试进行一次轻松愉快的对话。你可以想象，在这场对话中，帕姆说：“哦，西西开始叫我帕梅拉了。你知道的，小心点，她可能也会开始叫你吉姆。哈哈哈哈。”然后他们就无话可说了。
It's like there was a time when that little tidbit would have delighted them. Mm-hmm. You know? And would have just led to a natural, easy conversation. I thought the scene was so well written. It really shows how disconnected Jim and Pam are. And I thought you guys played it perfect.
就好像曾经有过那么一段时间，那个小花絮会让他们感到高兴。嗯哼。你知道吗？并且会自然而然地引出一场轻松的对话。我觉得这场戏写得太好了。它真实地展现了吉姆和帕姆之间有多么脱节。而且我觉得你们演得完美极了。
And I had to ask Jen about it. Here's what she had to say. We ended up shooting the phone call between Pam and Jim with John and Jenna on the set. And we shot it with them talking into the cell phone. And I think I was on set with Jenna. And then I was able to give notes over to John. And I love that scene.
我不得不问珍关于这场戏的看法。她是这样说的：我们最终让约翰和珍娜在片场拍摄了帕姆和吉姆之间的电话通话。我们让他们对着手机说话。我想我当时和珍娜在片场。然后我能够把笔记传达给约翰。我喜欢那个场景。
And it loves a weird word, because it's just awkward and a bit sad and distant. But I like that it felt very real as opposed to, I feel like we talked about versions or things where what they were talking about was more, a little bit more of a disjointed thing or a disconnection. But what I kind of love is that it's just the silence, the space between the pauses, the looks, all the things that were my favorite in terms of digging into things at the office. And I just thought that they performed it so well, the feeling of disconnect and Pam a bit yearning and wanting for it to be made better, and Jim being uncomfortable and not being sure
“喜欢”是个奇怪的词，因为它只是尴尬、有点悲伤和疏离。但我喜欢它感觉非常真实，而不是像我们谈论过的某些版本那样，他们谈论的话题更像是某种语无伦次的脱节。但我有点喜欢的是那种沉默、停顿之间的空间、眼神，所有这些都是我最喜欢的深入挖掘办公室日常的元素。我只是觉得他们表演得太棒了那种脱节的感觉，帕姆有些渴望并希望事情能变好，而吉姆则感到不自在并且不确定该如何解决。
how to fix it. Well, I remember shooting the scene, and there's this moment where Pam is like, hey, your assistant said that Ryan Howard is coming into the office, what's that about? And Jim's like, no, no, no, Ryan Howard, the first baseman for the Phillies. And she's like, oh yeah, I thought that would have been weird.
好吧，我还记得拍摄这场戏时的情景，有这样一个时刻：帕姆说：“嘿，你的助手说莱恩·霍华德要来办公室了，那是怎么回事？”吉姆说：“不，不，不，莱恩·霍华德，费城人队的一垒手。”然后她说：“哦，对，我还以为那会很奇怪呢。”
And you know, this is obviously a big meeting for Jim. Why is Pam hearing about it from his assistant? Why haven't they talked the night before? And he says, hey, I have a big day tomorrow. Here's what's going on. Yeah, it's a little confusing. And actually, Pam would have gotten kind of snarky with him at the end of this phone call.
你知道的，这显然是吉姆的一个重要会议。为什么帕姆是从他的助手那里听到这个的？为什么他们前天晚上没有聊过？而吉姆却说：“嘿，我明天有个大日子。事情是这样的。”是的，这有点令人困惑。事实上，在这次电话的最后，帕姆本来会对他说风凉话的。
We shot it. They cut it. But Pam was going to say, well, I hope it was worth leaving early yesterday for this. And Jim was supposed to say, do you really hope that? Or is it more fun for you to be mad at me? Oh my gosh. Mm-hmm.
我们拍了。他们剪掉了。但帕姆本来要说：“好吧，我希望为了这个而昨天提前早退是值得的。”而吉姆本该回答：“你真的是这么希望的吗？还是说生我的气对你来说更有趣？”哦天哪。嗯哼。
Yeah. Well, John and I did not love that ending, especially since we knew that Pam was going to end up seeing Brian later. We didn't love the idea that Jim and Pam would be kind of like in a fight. Yeah. Yeah.
好吧，约翰和我都不喜欢那个结局，尤其是当我们知道帕姆后来会去见布赖恩的时候。我们不喜欢让吉姆和帕姆看起来像是在吵架的这种设定。是的。是的。
When she goes to see Brian. We thought, fine, if there's like that distance, they're not connecting. So we took that out. This scene of them so disconnected was enough. Enough. It's Jim and Pam. It's scary enough.
当她去见布赖恩的时候。我们想，好吧，如果那种距离感就在那里，他们无法连结。所以我们把那段删了。这场他们如此脱节的戏已经足够了。足够了。这是吉姆和帕姆。这已经够吓人的了。
And they have nothing to talk about. Yeah, bad, bad. Before we move on to the next scene, I so apologize, but I need to ask you, do I just look younger today? Because I tried new makeup, a tutorial on Instagram. Apparently I've been putting my makeup on wrong. I've been weighing down my face
而且他们无话可说。是的，太糟糕了。在我们进入下一个场景之前，我非常抱歉，但我需要问你：我今天看起来是不是变年轻了？因为我尝试了一种新妆容，是 Instagram 上的一个教程。显然我以前一直把妆画错了。我用修容和高光的位置把我的脸拉垮了。
with my contour and highlight positioning. And so I put it in different places to try to lift. Do you need to not watch Instagram tutorials? I know. I think you look great, but I feel like this is a slippery slope. I feel like the next thing is going to be like, so here's the thing I discovered about my eyebrows. I'm going to be like, no, no, no, don't mess with your eyebrows.
所以我把它们放在了不同的地方来尝试提拉。你是不是不需要看 Instagram 教程了？我知道。我觉得你看起来很棒，但我觉得这是一条滑坡效应。我觉得接下来发生的事会是：“所以这是我发现的关于我的眉毛的事。”我会说：“不，不，不，别动你的眉毛。”
I feel like I look either the same, maybe worse. Well, maybe it's just different. I would like to say this. Sam's shaking his head, he's like, I see. I can't tell the difference, I'm sorry. That's better than worse. Well, it's difficult for me because we have such beautiful natural light
我觉得我看起来要么一样，要么更糟。好吧，也许只是不同。我想说的是：萨姆在摇头，他的表情是：我懂。我看不出区别，我很抱歉。总比更糟要好。好吧，这对我来说很难，因为我们有这么美丽的自然光，
that you look so lovely because these windows are just, we're sitting in front of windows, people. This is a wonderful thing. And if I'm going to be real honest, the natural light, you look fabulous. But you also don't really look like you have a lot of makeup on.
所以你看起来如此迷人，因为这些窗户就在那儿，我们在窗户前面，各位。这是一件美妙的事。如果我要说实话的话，在自然光的衬托下，你看起来棒极了。但你看起来其实也没有化很多妆。
Is that the idea? I don't know. Well, I don't know. I braided my hair in the elevator, can you tell? No, it looks real cute. Thank you. Didn't need a video for that. I am so suggestible to the Instagram videos.
是这个效果吗？我不知道。好吧，我不知道。我在电梯里编了头发，你看得出来吗？不，看起来挺可爱的。谢谢。没必要为此看视频。我对 Instagram 视频太容易受暗示了。
I know, honey, I know. I saw this woman, she told me I was doing my contour wrong. I'm like, ah, I gotta fix that. You and Oscar, Oscar the character. I know, you buy what you see online. I do. I really really do. All right well speaking of Oscar and his computer how about that for a segue? Love it. The trailer for the documentary has been released everyone. Everyone gathers around Oscar's computer they're gonna watch it together. Which is
我知道，亲爱的，我知道。我看到这个女人告诉我我的修容做错了。我当时就想：啊，我得把它改过来。你和奥斯卡——奥斯卡那个角色。我知道，你在网上看到什么就买什么。我确实是。我真的、真的会买。好吧，说到奥斯卡和他的计算机，这过渡得怎么样？太喜欢了。
so special. It's art imitating life because we would gather around Oscar's computer in real life because it was the only one that had sound. Yes, that's true. Well, in this promo there are a few things. WVIA are the real call letters for the Scranton PBS affiliate. So this is going to run on PBS. Love it. We asked Jen Salata if she picked the clips for the promo, and she said no, that it had already been put together. And I did notice that some shots were specifically called out in the script. Here's how it was described. Quote, we see a promo for The Office colon an American workplace,
纪录片的预告片发布了，所有人。大家都聚集在奥斯卡的计算机周围，准备一起观看。这太特别了。简直是艺术模仿生活，因为我们在现实生活中也会聚集在奥斯卡的计算机周围，因为那是唯一一台有声音的计算机。是的，确实如此。好吧，在这个预告片里有几件事。WVIA 是斯克兰顿 PBS 附属电视台的真实呼号。所以这个将在 PBS 上播出。
which incidentally was the name of our show the first season. Then in season two, we changed it to Just the Office. The script went on to say, it is a montage of scenes favoring the first years of the documentary, including Andy playing Rainbow Connection and Pam and Jim on the roof in The Client. All of the dialogue for the promo voiceover was scripted. Steve Burgess believes that it was voiced by Peter Coyote and he is a very famous narrator. He did narration for the opening ceremonies of the 2002 Winter Olympics. He won a Primetime Emmy Award for Outstanding Narrator in 2015 for his work on the Ken Burns documentary miniseries, The Roosevelts and Intimate History. We also got a fan question about this promo.
太棒了。我们问过珍·萨拉塔她是否为预告片挑选了剪辑片段，她说没有，那是早就剪辑好的。我确实注意到有些镜头在剧本里被特别提及。它是这样描述的：“引文：我们看到《办公室：美国职场》的预告片，顺便说一句，这也是我们第一季节目的名字。然后到了第二季，我们把它改成了仅仅叫《办公室》。”剧本接着写道：“这是一组偏向纪录片头几年的场景剪辑，包括安迪演奏《彩虹的那端》（Rainbow Connection），以及帕姆和吉姆在《客户》（The Client）那一集里坐在屋顶上。”预告片画外音的所有台词都是剧本写好的。史蒂夫·伯吉斯相信这是由彼得·科约特（Peter Coyote）配音的，他是一位非常著名的旁白。他曾为 2002 年冬季奥运会开幕式担任旁白。他因在肯·伯恩斯（Ken Burns）纪录片迷你剧《罗斯福家族：一部亲密的史诗》（The Roosevelts: An International History）中的工作，获得了 2015 年黄金时段艾美奖杰出旁白奖。我们还收到了一个关于这个预告片的粉丝提问。
It might be a fan soap box. Oh. It's from JRP in Shlomp. Shlomp? You cannot say to me about art imitating life because every time it gets to a city that you're like, how do you say this? Schomburg, Illinois.
这可能是一个粉丝的个人长篇大论。哦。来自施隆普（Shlomp）的 JRP。施隆普？你不能跟我说艺术模仿生活，因为每次说到某个城市你都会说：“这怎么读？”绍姆堡，伊利诺伊州。
Are you sure it's not Schlongberg? It's not Schlongberg. Why did I put the L? It's hard to say. Okay. Don't you want to add the L? Schomburg, Illinois. JR says, in this episode, when we see the go-to box screen for the documentary on Oscar's computer,
你确定不是施隆堡（Schlongberg）吗？不是施隆堡。我为什么要加个 L 呢？这很难读。好吧。难道你不想加个 L 吗？绍姆堡，伊利诺伊州。JR 说，在这集里，当我们在奥斯卡的计算机上看到纪录片的 GoTo 画面时，
it says, the office and American workplace, nine nights in May. But then we see Andy playing the banjo for Pam, which is season three, which means this promo video is promoting quite a bit of filming that the documentary crew did. And when Pam talks to Brian at his apartment, she says, so we basically had no privacy for 10 years. And then in all caps, all caps, it says, I have never understood how 10 years of filming was aired in nine episodes on PBS. Please explain. Seriously, how long are these episodes? Well, that's, I guess the question. Maybe each one is two hours. I don't know. But it seems like 10 years of footage cut down to like an hour or two hours?
上面写着，“办公室与美国职场，五月的九个夜晚”。但接着我们看到安迪为帕姆弹班卓琴，那是第三季的内容，这意味着这段宣传视频宣传了纪录片摄制组拍摄的大量内容。当帕姆在布赖恩的公寓和他交谈时，她说，所以我们基本上有10年毫无隐私可言。然后是大写字母，全部是大写字母，写着，我一直不明白10年的拍摄内容怎么会在PBS的九集里播完。请解释一下。说真的，这些集到底有多长？嗯，这大概就是问题所在。也许每一集有两个小时。我不知道。但感觉就像10年的素材被剪辑成了一个小时或两个小时？
Nine times. I feel bad for that editor. It was like every season had to be one episode if it was nine episodes. And we did nine seasons. So they paid for these guys, this crew, to be there for 10 years, and they only got nine hours of footage out of it?
九次。我替那个剪辑师感到难过。如果是九集的话，感觉每一季都得是一集。而且我们拍了九季。所以他们花钱请这些人，这个摄制组，在那里待了10年，结果只剪出了9个小时的素材？
Yeah, that doesn't make any sense. It's not worth it. JR, we hear you. We really do. Well, I guess Kevin has missed all this because he was in the bathroom, and when he comes out, he's like, "'Wow, so much has changed during 45 minutes
对，这根本说不通。不值得。杰里米，我们听到你的心声了。真的。好吧，我猜凯文错过了这一切，因为他去洗手间了，等他出来时，他说：“哇，在我上洗手间的45分钟里，
"'that I was in the bathroom. That's when Kevin realizes that they're in a documentary. He thought they were specimens in a human zoo. What is happening with Kevin? I don't know. In the shooting draft there was an alt talking head for this. Kevin would have said I'm going to be in a documentary on TV. This could be great for my band. We love watching TV. Oh, so it would just be something for the band to do. Not exposure for their band. Right.
发生了这么多变化。”就在那时，凯文意识到他们正在拍纪录片。他以为他们是人类动物园里的标本。凯文这是怎么了？我不知道。在拍摄剧本中，这里有一个备选的“面对镜头独白”。凯文会说，我要上电视纪录片了。这对我的乐队来说太棒了。我们喜欢看电视。哦，所以这只是乐队可以做的一件事。而不是给他们的乐队曝光。没错。
Then there was a series of Talking Heads where the Dunder Mifflin group realized they might become famous. I want you to hear Meredith's, then Angela's, and then Toby's. If you're watching the documentary, you know my deal. Hit me up at meredithatgpostmail.com, or just come over and show a little class. Bring some Pringles.
接下来是一系列的独白，邓德米夫林的成员们意识到他们可能会成名。我想让你们听听梅雷迪思的，然后是安吉拉的，最后是托比的。如果你在看纪录片，你就知道我的情况。通过meredithatgpostmail.com联系我，或者直接过来表现得有点档次。带点品客薯片。
Oh, more celebrity. As if being the widely recognized wife of a senator isn't limelight enough. The other day at the grocery store, they opened up another register for me. It is embarrassing! Hi Sasha, look your daddy's on tv. Your real daddy, not your mommy's boyfriend. Please go back to calling him Jamie. Toby? I know Toby. And of course Meredith hopes she can get a date out of this and then Angela's like like, oh my gosh, even more celebrity.
哦，更多的名人效应。好像当一个广为人知的参议员妻子还不够引人注目似的。前几天在杂货店，他们专门为我开了一个新收银台。太尴尬了！嗨，萨莎，看你爸爸上电视了。你真正的爸爸，不是你妈妈的男友。请改口叫他杰米吧。托比？我认识托比。当然，梅雷迪思希望借此能约会，然后安吉拉就像是，哦天哪，甚至更出名了。
How will she handle it? But the last one was of Creed. It's in deleted scenes. I'm gonna share it in stories because it is hilarious. There is no audio. It's a site gag, but basically Creed is in the talking head chair and he just starts looking at the camera as if he's realized for the first time
她将如何应对？但最后一个是克里德的。在删减片段里。我会在快照里分享它，因为它太搞笑了。没有音频。这是一个视觉笑话，但基本上克里德坐在独白椅上，他开始看着镜头，就好像他第一次意识到
that there's been a camera. And he walks up to it, and he comes, this is how it's described in the shooting draft. Creed curiously gets out of his chair and comes really close to the camera lens with his head cocked like a bear in a nature show. Do you remember the first time after The Office started airing
有摄像机存在一样。他走向它，走过来，拍摄剧本里是这样描述的。克里德好奇地从椅子上站起来，非常靠近摄像机镜头，像自然纪录片里的一只熊一样歪着头。你还记得《办公室》开播后
where you felt like people were noticing you? This idea of like, okay, now you've been on TV for a little bit and maybe. Yeah, I actually remember the first time, I think because I was with a group of friends and they all teased me about it, but we were going to see a Sunday matinee at the ArcLight. Uh-huh.
第一次觉得自己被人们注意到的情景吗？这种感觉就像，好吧，现在你上了一会儿电视，也许。是的，我其实还记得第一次，我想是因为我和一群朋友在一起，他们都拿这取笑我，但我们当时正要去ArcLight看一场周日的日场电影。嗯哼。
You know, I was with my friends Michael and Tobias. This was their tradition. And you could eat lunch at the ArcLight, you know, and then go in for your movie. I got recognized waiting in line to get our tickets. And they were like, whoa. And I was like, that was so weird. Oh my God. This is so crazy, Angela. The first time I got recognized for the office was also at the ArcLight. Stop it.
你知道的，我和我的朋友迈克尔还有托比亚斯在一起。这是他们的传统。你可以在ArcLight吃午饭，你知道的，然后进去看电影。我在排队买票时被认出来了。他们说，哇。然后我说，这也太诡异了。哦天哪。太疯狂了，安吉拉。我第一次因为《办公室》被认出来也是在ArcLight。少来。
You know why? I think the people who worked there, they were our demographic. Yes. Because we didn't have huge ratings, but these were people who loved film and television and they were watching all the newest stuff and they were kind of interested in this show, this version of the British show, and I was buying popcorn
你知道为什么吗？我觉得在那儿工作的人，他们就是我们的目标受众。是的。因为我们的收视率不是很高，但这些人热爱电影和电视，他们观看所有最新的内容，而且他们对这部剧、英国剧的这个版本有点兴趣，当时我正在ArcLight
at the ArcLight and the person recognized me and then they all the people kind of recognized me. And this is like the OG ArcLight with the Cinerama Dome in Hollywood. Yeah. Same. That's crazy. Isn't it sad that that's closed down now? Yeah, I think about it a lot actually.
买爆米花，那个人认出了我，然后所有人都有点认出了我。这就是好莱坞那个带有西艺拉玛穹顶的OG ArcLight。没错。一样。太疯狂了。现在那个地方关门了，是不是很让人难过？对，我其实经常想起它。
It was a special place. It was. And then of course it's kind of special that years later that's where the premiere for the 40 year old Virgin was. Yes. Where I showed my underwear on the red carpet. Where you showed your underwear and I couldn't find the bathroom
那是一个特别的地方。确实是。然后当然，多年后《四十岁的老处男》的首映礼就在那里举行，这挺特别的。是的。我在红毯上露出了内衣。你露出了内衣，而我找不到洗手间，
and I missed the red carpet. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I did find the bathroom. I would say. You know what I mean. You know what, I'm going to share a picture of it. Do. Yeah.
错过了红毯。对。对。我是说，我确实找到洗手间了。我想这么说。你知道我的意思。你知道吗，我要分享一张照片。快去。好。
Where are we? Well, everyone now is watching the footage on their own computers. And Angela realizes they grabbed some stuff, like Dwight smacking her on the butt. Kevin sees it too. He tries to show it to Angela, but he unplugs his whole computer. And Pam is watching her and Jim's courtship. Yeah she's watching that scene of them up on the roof having the grilled cheese sandwiches. I loved that they picked that scene because that was one of my favorite scenes to shoot on the whole series. I've talked about it before. It was a warm
我们在哪？好吧，现在每个人都在自己的电脑上观看素材。安吉拉意识到他们抓拍到了一些东西，比如德怀特拍她屁股。凯文也看到了。他试图把它展示给安吉拉，但他把整个电脑都拔掉了。帕姆在看她和吉姆的追求过程。是的，她在看他们在屋顶上吃烤奶酪三明治的那场戏。我很高兴他们选了那场戏，因为那是整个系列中我最喜欢的拍摄场景之一。我以前说过。那是一个温暖的
summer evening. You had a grilled cheese sandwich. It was delicious. It was so wonderful and I was coming toward the end of this series and for me seeing that footage of how far we had come brought up real feelings of nostalgia. Yeah. Well Clark is gonna tease Pam. He says, you fell in love with that hair. Yeah. And Pam's like, it wasn't so bad. Yeah.
夏日傍晚。你吃了一个烤奶酪三明治。太好吃了。太棒了，而且我当时正接近这个系列的尾声，对我来说，看到我们一路走来的那些录像，勾起了我真实的怀旧之情。是的。好吧，克拉克要取笑帕姆了。他说，你爱上了那种发型。是的，帕姆说，其实也没那么糟。是的。
Andy, oh, poor Andy. He is thrilled at his little piece of fame that's happening. He said someone named Chobble Gobbler really liked his banjo playing, said it was aight. Yeah. As you can imagine, there were lots of Andy alts. But also in the shooting draft Andy would have gotten a text from Broccoli Rob. Oh really? Oh yeah.
安迪，哦，可怜的安迪。他为自己发生的这一点点名气兴奋不已。他说一个叫乔布尔·戈布勒的人非常喜欢他弹班卓琴，说还算凑合。是的。正如你所想象的那样，有很多安迪的备选台词。但在拍摄剧本中，安迪本来会收到来自西兰花罗布的短信。哦，真的吗？哦，是的。
Here's how it was scripted and then I'll read you an alt. Andy reads, Congrats Hollywood! Can't wait to see you on the small screen. FML. What's FML mean? F*** my life. That's what it means? Yes, how did you not know that?
剧本是这样写的，然后我读一段备选给你听。安迪读道，恭喜好莱坞！等不及在小屏幕上看到你了。FML。FML是什么意思？去死吧（F*** my life）。就是这个意思？是的，你怎么会不知道这个？
How did you know that? I don't know. I know these things. I'm hip. I am hip. I didn't know hot to trot. And I didn't know that other thing, which I'm so embarrassed still about,
你是怎么知道的？我不知道。我知道这些事。我很赶时髦。我很时髦。我不知道“迫不及待”（hot to trot）是什么意思。我也不知道另一件事，我现在对此仍然感到非常尴尬，
which I still am not ready to talk about on the podcast. I know. Someday I'll share. It's okay. Okay. Do you want to hear the other Broccoli Rob alt? Here's the alt. Congrats, big man.
以至于我还准备好在播客里谈论它。我知道。总有一天我会分享的。没关系。好吧。你想听另一个西兰花罗布的备选吗？备选是这样的。恭喜，大个子。
That small screen is perfect for your tiny ween. Baby Brox. Mmm. Baby Brox. This is his nickname for himself. Yeah. I wish we would have seen a little bit of broccoli robs. What should we say?
那个小屏幕非常适合你那细小的老二。小布罗克斯。嗯。小布罗克斯。这是他给自己起的外号。是的。我真希望能看到一点西兰花罗布的戏份。我们该怎么说呢？
Jealousy over Andy's fame. I love their rivalry. It just delights me. So I'm sad that got cut out. Well, Ryan Howard is now going to arrive at the athlete office. Well, I loved his entrance. I thought it was so funny and set up who this version of himself was
对安迪名气的嫉妒。我喜欢他们的竞争关系。这太让我开心了。所以我很难过这部分被剪掉了。好吧，瑞安·霍华德现在要来到阿特利办公室了。好吧，我喜欢他的出场。我觉得太搞笑了，并且确立了这一版本的他是怎样的一个人。
gonna be. We asked Jen about shooting this and here's what she had to say. I remember talking to him about camera awareness when he first gets off the elevator. He sees the documentary crew and has like a little bit of a reaction there and at first he was saying to Jim and then to Darryl eat fresh but we said oh, hey like, you know, maybe throw one to the camera because you're really trying to support Subway and eat fresh and promote them and So he did it just like so naturally and did a wink to the camera. It was it was fantastic I thought he was so much fun and It was really neat having him around
我们问了珍关于拍摄这场戏的感受，她是这么说的。我记得在他刚出电梯时跟他谈过对摄像机的敏感度。他看到了纪录片摄制组，当时有一点反应，起先他对吉姆说，然后对达里尔说“吃新鲜的”，但我们说，哦，嘿，你知道的，也许对着镜头也来一下，因为你真的是在支持赛百味（Subway）、吃新鲜的并为他们宣传，所以他表现得非常自然，还对镜头眨了眨眼。这太棒了，我觉得他太有趣了，有他在身边真的很酷。
I thought he was so much fun and it was really neat having him around. Well back at Dunder Mifflin in the kitchen, Dwight is looking for food for Esther. And of course Angela has to make a joke at Esther's expense. And then Aaron says, Dwight, your guests have arrived. They look like they're from the forest or where they harvest paper or something. Angela is delighted. She's like, woo hoo hoo. I can't wait to see. Did you notice that if you look over Ellie's like, woohoohoo, I can't wait to see.
我觉得他太有趣了，有他在身边真的很酷。回到邓德米夫林的厨房，德怀特正在为埃丝特找吃的。当然，安吉拉忍不住拿埃丝特开玩笑。然后艾琳说，德怀特，你的客人们到了。他们看起来像是从森林里来的，或者是去那里收割纸张什么的。安吉拉很高兴。她就像是，呼呼呼。我等不及要看了。你有没有注意到，如果你看艾莉的像，呼呼呼，我等不及要看了。
Did you notice that if you look over Ellie's shoulder into the bullpen, you can't see any guests? There's no one standing at reception. But then when you and Dwight walk into the bullpen, suddenly there's like five people standing there. Yeah. Dwight goes up and he greets the Brueger family. He gives Esther a kiss on her forehead. And Angela is taken aback. She was not expecting Esther to be so beautiful. And it's going to set up a whole storyline.
你有没有注意到，如果你越过艾莉的肩膀看办公大区，你看不到任何客人？前台没有人站着。但当你和德怀特走进办公大区时，突然有大约五个人站在那里。是的。德怀特走过去迎接布鲁格一家。他在埃丝特的额头上亲了一下。安吉拉大吃一惊。她没想到埃丝特会这么漂亮。这将会引发一整条故事线。
Angela is jealous. Well, like we mentioned last week, Esther was played by Nora Kirkpatrick. And you know, we reached out to her and she talked to us a little bit about her time on the office. And one of the things we were curious about was when exactly did she find out that her role would be recurring? Because originally she was going to be a regular character on the farm if that had gone.
安吉拉嫉妒了。嗯，就像我们上周提到的，埃丝特由诺拉·柯克帕特里克饰演。你知道的，我们联系了她，她跟我们聊了聊她在《办公室》的时光。我们好奇的事情之一是，她究竟是什么时候发现自己的角色会是常驻角色的？因为如果那个剧集拍成的话，她原本会是《农场》里的常规角色。
So Nora said that shortly after hearing that the farm was not getting picked up, they pitched the idea of bringing Esther into the later episodes of the office season as kind of a detour for the Angela Dwight storyline. By this time, they had decided that Angela and Dwight would eventually end up together, but they wanted to pump the brakes on that. Nora said she was thrilled to do it and also very happy that in the end Dwight got to end up with his one true love Angela. She's so nice. I know. I love that she's rooting for Dwight and Angela even though she's playing the foil
所以诺拉说，在听说《农场》没有被续签后不久，他们就提出了这样一个想法：让埃丝特加入《办公室》这一季后面的剧集中，作为安吉拉和德怀特故事线的一个支线。到这个时候，他们已经决定安吉拉和德怀特最终会走到一起，但他们想在这上面踩一下刹车。诺拉说她很高兴能参与其中，也很高兴最终德怀特能和他的真爱安吉拉在一起。她人太好了。我知道。我喜欢她虽然扮演的是衬托的主角，但依然支持德怀特和安吉拉。
character. Well why don't we take a break because when we come back the Dunder Mifflin crew discovers more footage is online. In Danish. Yeah. All right. We are back and Pam is in the kitchen. So is Stanley. Pam says, isn't it crazy? The promo really made her realize how some of us have changed over the years. I mean, she's talking about Jim, I think. But according to Stanley, they've all changed.
我们为什么不休息一下呢，因为当我们回来时，邓德米夫林的成员们会发现更多的网段视频。是丹麦语的。是的。好的。我们回来了，帕姆在厨房里。斯坦利也在。帕姆说，是不是很疯狂？这段宣传片真的让她意识到这些年来我们中的一些人是如何改变的。我是说，我想她在说吉姆。但根据斯坦利的说法，大家都变了。
We got a fan question from Taryn G and Abilene Kansas who said, I have been waiting since the podcast started to ask this question. Wow. When Pam is talking to Stanley, he is eating a pretzel. Did we miss out on a deleted scene or a storyline about it being Pretzel Day? Well, Taryn, I looked this up.
我们收到了来自堪萨斯州阿比林的粉丝泰伦·G的一个问题，他说，自从播客开播以来，我一直在等著问这个问题。哇。当帕姆和斯坦利交谈时，他正在吃 pretzel（蝴蝶结饼干）。我们是不是错过了一个被删掉的场景，或者关于今天是 pretzel 日的故事线？嗯，泰伦，我查过了。
I was curious as well. And this scene was performed exactly as it's scripted. This is what it said, Interior Kitchen, Pam ventures to share with Stanley. He is lost in his crossword, eating a pretzel. That's it. I think it's meant to show that Stanley hasn't changed at all.
我也很好奇。这个场景完全是按照剧本表演的。上面是这样写的，内景厨房，帕姆试图与斯坦利分享。他沉迷于填字游戏，吃着蝴蝶结饼干。就是这样。我觉得这是为了说明斯坦利一点都没变。
That's what I thought. And it's interesting that it was scripted for him to have the pretzel, because I thought it was that visual button to him saying, we've all changed, but really he kind of hasn't. Not at all. He really hasn't.
我也是这么想的。有趣的是，剧本里写了让他吃饼干，因为我以为那是他所说“我们都变了”的视觉呼应，但实际上他基本没变。一点也没变。他真的没变。
He really hasn't. He's been very consistent. And I think it just only highlights the way that Jim has changed for Pam. Well speaking of Jim, we're back at Athlete now and Ryan Howard tells Jim and Darryl about his aspirations post baseball. He has big plans. Well, and that's what their company is about. Their company is about helping sports celebrities segue into right like promotions and
他真的没变。他一直非常如一。我觉得这只是突显了吉姆为帕姆改变的方式。说到吉姆，我们现在回到了阿特利公司，瑞安·霍华德向吉姆和达里尔讲述了他退役后的宏伟志向。他有很大的计划。嗯，这就是他们的公司所做的。他们的公司是关于帮助体育名人顺利过渡到正确的宣传领域，以及
what is his business. I don't know any more than Pam does. I really don't. I think that's what it is. All they seem like branding is like agents for athletes to do things outside of their sport. Right. Yes. And something though that I have wondered is why their sports agent can't handle them for that. Is that not a thing? Do you, they just handle your sports contracts and so you need a type of branding agent or
他的业务是什么。我知道的不比帕姆多。我真的不知道。我想就是这样。他们看起来像是品牌策划，就像运动员在他们体育项目之外开展活动的经纪人。对。是的。不过我一直想知道的一件事是，为什么他们的体育经纪人不能帮他们处理这些？这不是常规操作吗？你知道的，他们只处理你的体育合同，所以你需要一种品牌经纪人，或者
a film and appearances agent. Okay, we have that. So I guess that makes sense. Ryan Howard says he would love to be an actor and he's actually written a screenplay. It's half biopic, half superhero movie, and he brought scripts so they could all read through it together. Very professional looking scripts. I thought so too. I'll have you know
电影和活动出场经纪人。好吧，我们有这个。所以我想这说得通。瑞安·霍华德说他很想成为一名演员，他实际上写了一个剧本。一半是传记片，一半是超级英雄电影，他带来了剧本，这样他们就可以一起读一遍。看起来非常专业的剧本。我也这么觉得。我要告诉你们的是
that in real life Ryan Howard along with his wife Crystal Howard has written five children's books. Aww. They are called Little Rhino. It's a series and they are for kids aged seven to ten years old and they're about a little boy who loves baseball. Cute. I read the foreword to one of those books and Ryan Howard wrote this, quote, I wasn't allowed to go to baseball practice until my homework was done. So it was the first thing I did when I got home from school. Homework before practice. Good grades before baseball games. Those were the rules growing up.
现实生活中，瑞安·霍华德和他的妻子克里斯塔尔·霍华德一起写了五本儿童书。哇。它们叫《小犀牛》。这是一套系列丛书，适合七到十岁的孩子，讲述了一个热爱棒球的小男孩的故事。可爱。我读了其中一本书的前言，瑞安·霍华德是这样写的，引文，我做完家庭作业之前是不准去练习棒球的。所以这是我放学回家后做的第一件事。先写作业再练习。先拿好成绩再打棒球比赛。这就是我长大的规矩。
And the books are really cool because that's sort of the theme. It's about a little kid who has to juggle schoolwork and friends and all that kind of stuff so he can play baseball, which is his one true love. And there's even one where he has to spend a night away from home because he's going to his first out-of-town baseball tournament. So he's dealing with nerves and homesickness. The series looks so sweet. Little Rhino.
这些书真的很酷，因为这就是主题。它讲述了一个小孩子如何在学业、朋友和所有这些事情之间寻找平衡，以便他能够打棒球，而这是他真正的挚爱。甚至有一集讲到他因为要去参加第一个外地棒球锦标赛而必须离家过夜。所以他在应对紧张情绪和思乡之情。这个系列看起来太温馨了。小犀牛。
You guys, if you have kids 7 to 10, check it out. We'll put it in stories. Yes. Well Andy is just living his best life with his new celebrity and of course he wants to have a conference room meeting so everyone can learn media training. My favorite thing in this scene is when Toby says, you know, I find it ironic that I'm gonna be a TV star because my last Toby Flinderson novel was about a murdered TV star and everyone's like, uh, well, while they're talking about their life, now that the promo has come out, guess what? Oscar runs in, he's found another promo and it's in Danish. Danish. Everyone is so tickled. Everyone gathers around
你们这些有7到10岁孩子的家长，去看看吧。我们会把它发到快照里。好的。安迪正因他的新名气过着他最好的生活，当然他想开一个会议室会议，这样每个人都可以学习媒体培训。我在这场戏中最喜欢的部分是托比说，你知道的，我觉得很讽刺的是我要成为一个电视明星，因为我的上一部托比·芬德森小说就是关于一个被谋杀的电视明星的，然后大家都在说，呃，好吧，当他们在谈论他们的生活时，既然宣传片已经播出了，你猜怎么着？奥斯卡跑进来，他发现了另一段宣传片，是丹麦语的。丹麦语。每个人都兴高采烈。大家又聚集在
Oscar's computer again. They're so delighted. There's new footage and you know they can't understand what's being said but they're watching it all. Yeah they start translating it and we find out that Kevin is referred to as Dumpster Man. Yeah. And Angela is 3 p.m. girl. And she's like why why would they say 3 p.m. girl? And then she sees why. I mean she knew why but then she's like oh my god they were filming then? They show footage of her and Dwight leaving their secret makeout space in the warehouse. Yeah their hookup closet. This is when everyone realizes that the crew has been filming even when they didn't know
奥斯卡的电脑周围。他们太高兴了。有了新的素材，你知道他们听不懂在说什么，但他们都在看。是的，他们开始翻译，我们发现凯文被称为“垃圾箱男”。是的。而安吉拉是“下午三点女孩”。她说为什么，他们为什么要说下午三点女孩？然后她看到了原因。我是说她知道原因，但接着她说，哦天哪，他们当时在拍摄？他们播放了她和德怀特离开仓库里他们秘密亲热地点的画面。是的，他们的偷情衣帽间。这时大家才意识到，摄制组甚至在他们不知道的时候也一直在拍摄，
it and they all turn and look into the camera. I remembered that moment. There are so many moments when we do this rewatch where I just remember exactly doing that scene in that moment and I remembered that. I remember how they yelled for us to look at the same time. Anyway, it just, I was like, oh my gosh, I remember that. I remember how they yelled for us to look at the same time. Anyway, it just, I was like, oh my gosh, I remember that. Well, there was a fan mail flurry about this Danish promo, which I guess wasn't in great Danish.
他们都转过身看着镜头。我记得那一刻。在我们进行这次重温时，有太多这样的时刻，我只是确切地记得当时拍那个场景的情景，我记得那个。我记得他们是怎么大喊让我们同时看过去的。不管怎样，我当时就像，哦天哪，我记得那个。我记得他们是怎么大喊让我们同时看过去的。不管怎样，我当时就像，哦天哪，我记得那个。好吧，关于这段丹麦语宣传片，大家发来了雪片般的粉丝邮件，我猜那并不是什么地道的丹麦语。
Oh no, it wasn't accurate. Steena D from Denmark said, "'My native language is Danish, "'and I can assure you that the language "'in the supposedly Danish promo is not Danish. I cannot understand it at all without subtitles. I don't even think it's a real language. Oh no. Emily A and Mads T from Denmark both agree that the language spoken in the Danish promo was more like a Swedish Norwegian gibberish. Gibberish. With a touch of Danish. Sasha C. from Denmark said the translations are funny but incorrect.
哦不，它不准确。来自丹麦的斯蒂娜·D说：“我的母语是丹麦语，我可以向你保证，所谓的丹麦语宣传片里的语言根本不是丹麦语。如果没有字幕，我根本听不懂。我甚至不觉得那是一门真正的语言。”哦不。来自丹麦的埃米莉·A和马兹·T都认为，丹麦语宣传片中说的话更像是瑞典语和挪威语的混合胡言乱语。胡言乱语。夹杂着一点丹麦语。来自丹麦的萨沙·C说，翻译很搞笑，但并不正确。
For example, you got this. Skarls de Prand actually means trash can, not dumpster man. So I don't know. Gosh, I feel like our writers were so good about details, but maybe somehow this one fell through the cracks. Well, I think it did according to all of these people from Denmark. Yeah. Yeah. Well, now everyone is freaking out about all this extra footage, except for Meredith. She's just pissed off. She's like, you know what? If I wanna show them, I show them what I wanna show them like right now, and she flashes everyone.
例如，你们翻译的这个。Skarls de Prand实际上意思是垃圾桶，而不是垃圾箱男。所以，我不知道。天哪，我觉得我们的编剧对细节的处理一直很棒，但也许这个地方不知怎么就漏掉了。好吧，根据所有这些丹麦人的说法，确实漏掉了。是的。好吧，现在每个人都对所有这些额外的素材吓坏了，除了梅雷迪思。她只是火大。她说，你知道吗？如果我想让他们看，我就把我当下想让他们看的展示给他们看，然后她向所有人当众裸露。
Erin wonders if they film them at night when they're sleeping. And Oscar kind of snaps at her. Yeah, then he apologizes and he has a talking head. He says, you know what? I've been very honest in ways that could jeopardize the political career of someone close to me. And you guys wouldn't do that, right? He's looking right at camera. Well, there were
艾琳想知道他们晚上睡觉时是不是也在拍。奥斯卡有点对她发飙了。是的，然后他道歉了，并有一段面对镜头的独白。他说，你知道吗？我一直以某种可能会危及我身边某人政治生涯的方式表现得非常诚实。而你们不会那样做的，对吧？他直视着镜头。好吧，这里有
some candy bag alts for this talking head. One was, he says, I've been very honest with you guys in a way that might seriously impact the political career of a very good friend of mine. You're not going to use any of that, are you? You're not planning on destroying our lives after all this time. Please don't make me the Camilla Parker Bowls of Scranton." Here's my question. Oscar, what did you think was going to happen? You say, I've been sharing with you. What? Come on now. I know. And then the other candy bag all just cracked me up because This is that part of Oscar that delights and all this he goes. Why does my life have to be so juicy?
一些备选的独白台词。其中一个是，他说，我一直以某种可能会严重影响我一位非常好的朋友的政治生涯的方式对你们非常诚实。你们不会使用这些的，对吧？你们不打算在这一切之后毁了我们的生活吧。请不要把我变成斯克兰顿的卡米拉·帕克·鲍尔斯（Camilla Parker Bowles）。”我的问题是，奥斯卡，你当时以为会发生什么？你说，我一直在和你们分享。什么？拜托。我知道。然后另一个备选台词简直把我逗乐了，因为这是奥斯卡身上那个让人忍俊不禁的部分，他说。为什么我的人生必须这么有八卦味？
Well, we got a fan question from Jordan in San Antonio, Texas Who said when everyone is watching the promo of the documentary at Oscars desk? There's a lot of footage that hasn't been seen before in any of the previous episodes Are these clips from previous episodes or did we have to come in and shoot new snippets dressed in our old clothing? I thought that was a really good question. Jordan, we did not shoot anything new for those promos. That was all old footage.
好吧，我们收到了来自德克萨斯州圣安东尼奥市的乔丹的一个粉丝问题，他说，当大家都在奥斯卡的办公桌前观看纪录片的宣传片时，有很多以前在任何前几集中都没有见过的画面。这些片段是以前剧集的素材，还是我们需要回来穿着旧衣服拍摄新的片段？我觉得这是一个非常好的问题。乔丹，我们并没有为那些宣传片拍摄任何新东西。那全部都是以前的素材。
And you know they have a lot of extra footage. They do. And I asked Steve Burgess, how did we clear that? Remember when we did that episode, gosh, what season is it where we do all the flashbacks? And we found out that like every time you used a clip from an old episode, you had to pay the director who shot that footage a fee. I was like, how did we put this little promo together? It must have been so expensive. How did we put this little promo together? It must have been so expensive.
你知道他们有很多额外的素材。他们确实有。我问史蒂夫·伯吉斯，我们是怎么清除版权的？还记得我们拍那一集的时候吗，天哪，我们拍所有闪回镜头的是哪一季？我们发现，每次你使用旧剧集的片段时，你都必须向拍摄该素材的导演支付一笔费用。当时我想，我们是怎么把这个小宣传片拼凑在一起的？一定很贵吧。我们是怎么把这个小宣传片拼凑在一起的？一定很贵吧。
So Steve Burgess said because the clips were from the office, airing on the office, we didn't have to get any special clearance from anyone, but we did have to pay anyone who was not in the episode, mostly Steve, a SAG scale payment. And the DGA, which is the Directors Guild, and the WGA, the Writers Guild, have a formula for how they would pay each of the writers or directors to use their clip. And he said he doesn't know how much it cost ultimately, but it was a lot of paperwork. I bet. Mm-hmm.
所以史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，因为这些片段来自《办公室》，并在《办公室》中播出，我们不需要得到任何人的特别许可，但我们必须向任何不在该剧集中的人，主要是史蒂夫，支付演员工会（SAG）标准报酬。而且导演工会（DGA）和编剧工会（WGA）有一个公式，用来计算他们如何向每个编剧或导演支付使用其片段的费用。他说他不知道最终花了多少钱，但有很多 paperwork（纸质文件）。我敢打赌。嗯哼。
Andy seems to be the only one that is just giddy that all this footage is going online. He says, we're killing it on the internet. Angela needs to go for a walk. She needs to think about things. Everyone else agrees and they sneak away to discuss. I also remember doing this scene. In the warehouse? Yeah, I so remember it.
安迪似乎是唯一一个因为所有这些素材上网而欣喜若狂的人。他说，我们在互联网上大获成功。安吉拉需要去散散步。她需要考虑一些事情。其他人表示同意，并偷偷溜出去讨论。我也记得拍这场戏的情景。在仓库里？是的，我太记得了。
I do too. They all turn off their mics and they're like, okay, what exactly do we think the crew got on tape? And Pete suggests, you know what, Pam, you should reach out to Brian to find out. I mean, she knows Brian. Maybe she could get some information for them. Yeah, they wanna know exactly how much of our private lives
我也是。他们都关掉麦克风，说，好吧，我们觉得摄制组到底拍到了什么？皮特建议，你知道吗，帕姆，你应该去找布赖恩了解一下。我是说，她认识布赖恩。也许她能为他们打听到一些消息。是的，他们想确切知道当这部纪录片播出时，我们的私生活会有多少被曝光。
are going to be exposed when this documentary airs. Well, there are two people who are not in this meeting in the warehouse, and they are Clark and Dwight. And that is because they're out in the parking lot along with a giant tractor. And Mr. Brueger is trying to propose a 60-40 split. Dwight wants a 50-50 split. Some of Esther's sisters are flirting with Clark.
好吧，仓库里有两个人没有参加这次会议，那就是克拉克和德怀特。那是因为他们和一台巨大的拖拉机一起在停车场。布鲁格先生正试图提议六四分成。德怀特想要五五分成。埃丝特的一些姐妹正在调戏克拉克。
I should let you know that Mr. Brueger was played by Alan Harvey. He has had recurring roles on Billions, The Man in the High Castle, and Mad Men. He is a standup comedian who was, incidentally, born in my hometown of St. Louis, Missouri. So there were two St. Louisans in this episode, Alan and Ryan Howard, I guess, and me, three.
我应该告诉你们，布鲁格先生由艾伦·哈维饰演。他在《亿万富翁》、《高堡奇人》和《广告狂人》中都有常驻角色。他是一位单口喜剧演员，顺便说一句，出生在我的家乡密苏里州圣路易斯。所以这一集里有两个圣路易斯人，艾伦和瑞安·霍华德，我猜，还有我，三个。
And Phyllis. Four. And Ellie. Five. Oh myyllis. Four. And Ellie. Five. Oh my goodness. Are there any more? And if Ken Quopp has directed any of those promo spots, he's sort of represented as well.
还有菲利斯。四个。还有艾莉。五个。哦，天哪。还有其他人吗？如果肯·夸普执导了其中任何一个宣传短片，他某种程度上也代表了圣路易斯。
Wow, St. Louis coming hard for this episode. I got curious. What is the cost of a new tractor? What are we talking about here? What is this contract that Dwight is entering into? What's he gonna be in for if he signs this deal? They're very expensive. I figured.
哇，圣路易斯对这一集的贡献可真大。我很好奇。一台新拖拉机要多少钱？我们在这里谈论的是什么？德怀特正在签订的是什么合同？如果他签了这笔交易，他会陷入什么境地？它们非常贵。我想也是。
I went to an article from Victoria Farm Equipment. It's called the ultimate guide to understanding how much does a tractor cost. I wanted to know. It said that the cost of a new tractor can vary greatly based on its size, power, and features. Am I telling you things you already know, Angela? Well, I would go with my dad. One of his favorite things to do was to go see what new tractors were out there. He had two. One was a really, really big Case International tractor, and the other one was a smaller blue
我读了一篇来自维多利亚农场设备的文章。它叫理解拖拉机价格的终极指南。我想知道。上面说新拖拉机的价格会根据其尺寸、功率和功能有很大差异。我是不是在跟你说一些你已经知道的事情，安吉拉？嗯，我会和我爸爸一起去。他最喜欢的事情之一就是去看看有什么新拖拉机。他有两个。一个是很大很大的凯斯国际拖拉机，另一个是较小的蓝色
Ford tractor. And then he had a Baylor, a Hay Baylor, and he had a front end loader. Now when you say he liked to see the new tractors, is this sort of like how maybe you see like an open house sign in your neighborhood and you just want to go looky-loo? You're not going to go buy it. You just want to see what's the latest? What are people doing? What are the new gadgets? Well, I guess larger tractors with an engine capacity greater than 100 horsepower
福特拖拉机。然后他有一个打捆机，一个干草打捆机，他还有一个前置装载机。当你说他喜欢看新拖拉机时，这有点像你在邻居那里看到一个“开放参观”的牌子，然后你就只是想去看看热闹？你不是要去买它。你只是想看看最新的是什么？人们在做什么？有什么新小工具？好吧，我想发动机排量大于100马力的大型拖拉机
can range between $50,000 and $80,000. Mid-sized tractors are more like $25,000 to $50,000. But then, like you said, there's all these attachments. So to really utilize a tractor's potential, you're going to want to equip it with different attachments. And each one of those attachments is more money. So all of this is to say, yeah, this is a big purchase. Yeah. Not only money wisewise but like in the future, maintaining the tractor and everything. Well Esther's sisters have kind of all gathered around Clark and he's really enjoying the attention and then one of them says you
价格在50,000到80,000美元之间。中型拖拉机大约是25,000到50,000美元。但正如你所说，还有所有这些附属装置。所以要真正发挥拖拉机的潜力，你会想要为它配备不同的附属装置。而每一个这样的附属装置都要花更多的钱。所以这一切都在说明，是的，这是一笔大买卖。是的，不仅是金钱方面，还有未来的拖拉机维护等等。好吧，埃丝特的姐妹们都围在了克拉克身边，他非常享受这种关注，然后其中一个说，你知道的，你很适合和她一起买一个螺旋钻，克拉克的脑子开始转动了。
know you would be a great one to buy an auger with and the wheels start turning for Clark. Yeah he goes over and interrupts Dwight and he's like, dude, we're being conned. Yeah, no one this hot would date us. They want something. Yeah, and Dwight's like, no, I don't think so. And then he says, she just said that I should buy an auger with her.
是的，他走过去打断了德怀特，他说，老兄，我们被骗了。是的，这么辣的人才不会跟我们约会呢。他们有所图。是的，德怀特说，不，我不这么认为。然后他说，她刚才说我应该和她一起买一个螺旋钻。
And he doesn't even know what an auger is. And Dwight is like, oh my gosh, no woman would want a man who doesn't know what an auger is. And Dwight is like, oh my gosh, no woman would want a man who doesn't know what an auger is. Yeah, and he tells Esther's dad, I'm gonna need a minute to think about this. Well, let me give you a quick guest star breakdown. Esther's sister Bertha was played by Kelly Daly. Her sister Edna was played by Kamala Jones.
而他甚至不知道螺旋钻是什么。德怀特就像，哦天哪，没有女人会想要一个不知道螺旋钻是什么的男人。德怀特就像，哦天哪，没有女人会想要一个不知道螺旋钻是什么的男人。是的，他对埃丝特的父亲说，我需要一分钟来考虑一下。好吧，我给你们简单介绍一下客串演员。埃丝特的姐姐伯莎由凯利·戴利饰演。她的妹妹埃德娜由卡马拉·琼斯饰演。
And then there was a nameless sister played by Wendy McComb, and the tractor seller was Richard Augustine. Well, back in the offices, Stanley's doing damage control. He calls his wife and says, Hey, you know what the TV repairman said? We need to keep our TV off for a couple of months. There's a wiring issue. That's the best excuse he could come up with.
然后还有一个没有名字的妹妹由温蒂·麦康布饰演，拖拉机卖家由理查德·奥古斯丁饰演。好吧，回到办公室，斯坦利正在进行危机公关。他给妻子打电话说，嘿，你知道电视修理工怎么说吗？我们需要把电视关上几个月。有电路问题。这是他能想到的最好的借口了。
It's not great. No. Andy is becoming obsessed with the comments section and some of the comments are snarky and he starts responding. Yes this is a slippery slope Andy be careful. Meanwhile in the secret stairwell. The super secret stairwell. Mm-hmm. Angela asks Oscar how much does the documentary crew know about you and the Senator? This scene was so much fun to film. You guys, we improvised the whole second half of it. The part we did a scripted was Oscar says, well, they caught us kissing on Halloween. And Angela goes, he was dressed as Reagan.
这并不高明。不。安迪开始沉迷于评论区，有些评论很尖酸刻薄，他开始回复。是的，这是一条滑坡，安迪，小心点。与此同时，在秘密楼梯间里。超级秘密楼梯间。嗯哼。安吉拉问奥斯卡，纪录片摄制组对你和参议员了解多少？拍摄这场戏太有趣了。你们知道吗，后半部分全是我们即兴发挥的。我们按剧本演的部分是奥斯卡说，好吧，他们在万圣节抓到我们接吻了。然后安吉拉说，他当时打扮成里根。
And she slaps him. And then Oscar says, will he kiss like Jack Kennedy? And she's like, and then she slaps him again. I improvised that next slap. And then he's like, stop slapping me. And I'm like, stop kissing him. All of that, we started improvising. And basically we didn't get back on script
然后她打了他的耳光。接着奥斯卡说，他吻起来像杰克·肯尼迪吗？她说，然后她又打了他一巴掌。后面那一巴掌是我即兴发挥的。然后他说，别再打我了。我说，别再去吻他了。所有这些，我们开始即兴发挥。基本上我们没有回到剧本
till the part where I say, well, you call him. No, you call him. Now everyone has this awareness that the documentary crew could be filming or listening in at any time. So during this whole exchange, Angela, you are playing Lee Greenwood's God Bless the USA on an old boombox. That was scripted.
直到我说，好吧，你打电话给他。不，你打电话给他。现在大家都意识到纪录片摄制组随时可能在拍摄或窃听。所以在整个交流过程中，安吉拉，你正在用一个旧音响放着李·格林伍德的《上帝保佑美国》。那是剧本安排的。
Yes, I asked DeBurgis about it. He said it was one of our more expensive music purchases. Oh, wow. $35,000. Wow. Mm-hmm. Well, Pam has decided she will will for the sake of everyone at the office go and find out from Brian what footage they have. Yes. You see her
是的，我问过德伯吉斯这件事。他说这是我们比较昂贵的音乐购买之一。哦，哇。3.5万美元。哇。嗯哼。好吧，帕姆决定为了办公室所有人的利益，去找布赖恩弄清楚他们到底有什么素材。是的。你看到她
walking down the street and she's kind of looking around like did I sneak away? Did I get away? And she doesn't see a camera. She gets to Brian's house and it is a mess. He's a bachelor now. He's such a mess. You see moving boxes. And he's embarrassed. He's like, sorry. He's like, let's go out to the balcony.
走在街上，她四处张望，就像，我溜出来了吗？我逃掉了吗？她没有看到摄像机。她到了布赖恩家，那里一团糟。他现在是个单身汉了。他太邋遢了。你看到搬家纸箱。他很尴尬。他说，抱歉。他说，我们去阳台吧。
He's going to get them some beers. Well, I remember this location. It was a real apartment complex in Woodland Hills. And all of this thing about them sitting on the balcony and his place being a mess, that was so that we could draw them outside. So that the audio could pick them up hypothetically. Right.
他去给他们拿几罐啤酒。好吧，我记得这个外景。这是伍德兰山的一个真实的公寓综合体。关于他们坐在阳台上以及他的住处一团糟的所有这些，都是为了把他们引到外面去。这样音频就可以收录到他们。没错。
That the documentary crew could capture this. Yeah, and they're gonna have this really intimate conversation. And I remember shooting it and it felt really intimate because we couldn't see the cameras like we usually do. You know, it felt like two people just having a conversation. I did find it very interesting that he went and got them beers. I'm like, all right, she's got to go back to work. This is day drinking. What is happening at this man's home?
这样纪录片摄制组就能捕捉到这个。是的，他们将进行一次非常亲密的对话。我记得拍摄时的情景，感觉真的很亲密，因为我们看不到像平时那样的摄像机。你知道的，感觉就像两个人只是在聊天。我确实觉得很有趣的是他去给他们拿了啤酒。我想，好吧，她得回去上班呢。这是在白天喝酒。这个男人的家里到底怎么了？
I was like, wait, what? I kind of got the sense that's all there was. Yeah, you know what I mean? That's what's in the fridge at this guy's place. But Pam kind of ends up blurting out, do you think Jim has changed? Am I crazy? And he says, no, you're not crazy. There's a line we took out here where Brian was going to say, I mean, if you want, I can show you Jim's theme sheet. Yeah. And Pam's like, what's a theme sheet? He's like, well, we kind of pick a theme for each person in the office, and then we are kind of told to try and capture that,
我想，等等，什么？我有点觉得那就只有那些了。是的，你知道我的意思吗？这就是这家伙冰箱里的东西。但帕姆最后还是脱口而出，你觉得吉姆变了吗？我疯了吗？他说，不，你没疯。这里我们删掉了一句台词，布赖恩本来说，我是说，如果你想的话，我可以给你看吉姆的主题表。是的。然后帕姆说，什么是主题表？他说，嗯，我们为办公室里的每个人挑选一个主题，然后我们被告知要试着捕捉这一点，
because that's what they're tending to do. And she's like, oh, what's Jim's theme? And he's like, Jim's theme right now is selfish. So the documentary crew would then try to capture any moment where they thought Jim was being selfish. Yeah. And tell that side of the story. Right.
因为这就是他们的倾向。然后她说，哦，吉姆的主题是什么？他说，吉姆目前的主题是自私。所以纪录片摄制组就会试着捕捉任何他们认为吉姆表现得自私的时刻。是的。并讲述故事的那一面。没错。
We ended up taking that out. We felt like that made the documentary crew seem a little bit less like a documentary crew and actually more like a reality TV crew. Yeah. Yeah, that's not really documentary. But anyway, he does say, no Pam, you're not crazy. And that kind of makes her feel better. And then she asks him, makes her feel better, but doesn't. Yeah, that's true. Then she starts saying, okay, well, the reason I'm here is because of this promo footage and people
我们最后把那段删掉了。我们觉得那会让纪录片摄制组看起来不那么像一个纪录片摄制组，而更像一个真人秀摄制组。是的。是的，那其实不算纪录片。不过无论如何，他说，不，帕姆，你没疯。这让她感觉好受了一些。然后她问他，让她感觉好受了一些，但其实并没有。是的，那是真的。然后她开始说，好吧，我来这里的理由是因为这段宣传片，大家
really are freaking out. How did that work? How much stuff did you really get? And this is when Brian says to her, you know what? We pretty much got everything. And she's like, well, what if we turned our mic packs off? And he says, well, the parabolic mics can pick up sound 100 yards away.
真的都吓坏了。那是怎么运作的？你们到底拍了多少东西？这时布赖恩对她说，你知道吗？我们基本上什么都拍到了。她说，好吧，如果我们把随身麦克风关掉呢？他说，嗯，抛物面麦克风可以在100码外收音。
So yeah, they got everything. And this really upsets Pam. She feels betrayed and she leaves. She's upset. Yeah, Jen Saladas sent in an amazing audio clip breaking down this whole scene from a director's perspective and we want you to hear it. I definitely remember there were a lot of discussions about the Pam Bryan scene.
所以，是的，他们什么都拍到了。这让帕姆非常沮丧。她觉得自己被背叛了，然后她离开了。她很难过。是的，珍·萨拉达斯发来了一段精彩的音频剪辑，从导演的角度剖析了整个场景，我们想让你们听听。我绝对记得当时关于帕姆和布赖恩的场景有很多讨论。
From a directing point of view, what I remember is a lot of thinking went into making it very clear that it was a spy shot and there was foliage featured in the foreground of the shot just to make it extra clear for two reasons. One, that I don't think that Pam would have been that vulnerable, surely, if she knew that there was any chance of a camera being there. And two, this was an episode where everybody was like hyper-focused that the camera crew caught things on camera that they didn't realize were on camera.
从导演的角度来看，我记得有很多心思都花在了确保让人非常清楚这是一个偷拍镜头上，镜头的最前方还特意安排了枝叶，主要是为了两个原因，让它更清晰。第一，我认为帕姆绝不可能在知道有任何摄像机存在的可能性的情况下，表现得那么脆弱。第二，这是一个大家都高度关注的剧集，摄像机组拍下了他们没有意识到被拍到的东西。
So it was really important to shoot it from further away. And what that meant was sacrificing a few things, like his look at the door when she comes to see him. And we ended up not seeing Brian's side for the stuff at the door, but we were able to focus and highlight Pam walking behind him, being out there on the balcony for a second by herself,
所以从更远处拍摄非常重要。这意味着要牺牲一些东西，比如她来找他时他对门那边的凝视。我们最终没有看到布赖恩在门那边的情况，但我们能够聚焦并突出帕姆跟在他身后，在阳台上独自待了一会儿，并真正选择在整个场景中将焦点放在帕姆身上，而不是像双人镜头那样更多地聚焦于帕姆。那些小的情绪转折，比如那种脆弱感，以及那种“我想问这家伙他有没有注意到什么”的感觉。我通常会和吉姆谈事情，而我现在觉得和吉姆有距离感。
and really chose to focus on Pam throughout behind him, being out there on the balcony for a second by herself, and really chose to focus on Pam throughout that scene, not using the two shot as much as the shot on Pam. Those little flips, like the vulnerability and the feeling like I wanna ask this guy if he noticed anything. I usually talk to Jim about things and I'm feeling distant from Jim right now
并且在整个场景中，真的选择把焦点放在帕姆身上，她独自在阳台上待了一会儿，整个场景中都把重点放在帕姆身上，没有过多使用双人镜头，而是多用了帕姆的单人镜头。那些微小的转变，比如那种脆弱感，以及那种“我想问这家伙有没有注意到什么”的心情。我通常会和吉姆聊这些事情，而我现在觉得和吉姆有些疏远了
and I just impulsively wanna ask. And then sort of realizing that she asked and pulling back a little and feeling a little bit exposed. And then on top of that, asking the question about the cameras and the privacy and how much they got on tape. And that feeling of now on top of feeling a little bit exposed, hearing that news,
I just love that scene and how it builds and I love Jenna's performance. And I just thought they did such a great job with that scene and how it builds, and I love Jenna's performance, and I just thought they did such a great job with that scene. Aw, that's so nice. I know. I was so glad that Jen was our director, because I just trusted her so much. She handled relationships for the character so well.
Mm-hmm. We got a fan question from Maddie S. in Russellville, Arkansas, who said, Jenna, how did you feel about Pam revisiting Brian the Boom Guy in this episode while her and Jim's relationship was still in such a tense stage? Do you think Pam told Jim she went to Brian's house that day? Please tell us your Pam and Jenna thoughts.
I don't think she told Jim she went to his house. I don't either. Not because she felt like she did something wrong, but I feel like Jim isn't the person she talks to right now. Yeah. I think I'm just remembering when they were at lunch and Jim found out that Pam and Brian had been talking more than he understood, and it caused tension, and I think Pam is avoiding all tension right now. So she just doesn't want to bring it up. It's like the last thing they need.
Yeah. Well, I think that's Pam's perspective. As Jenna, I will say that this Pam-Brian story went through many, many iterations as they always did, as they had been. In the table draft for this, the script we read at the table read, Brian hit on Pam when she went to the apartment. Oh no.
Mm-hmm. How did he hit on her? Well, they start by discussing the promos. So she gets all her promo questions out of the way first, and then he was going to say, how are you doing? And Pam was going to say, oh, fine, kids are fine, Jim's fine, I'm fine, I think we're fine. She sort of repeats the word fine. And then Brian was going to say, okay, so things are fine, but are they good? And then Pam was gonna be like, well, what do you mean? And he says, are you happy?
And then it was scripted that he was gonna brush some of her hair away from her face and say that maybe it's not his place to say it, but he thinks she deserves better, that she's an amazing woman, and she should be with someone who tells her how amazing she is all the time. And then Pam was going to get really angry and say, never call me again. Well, how do you think that went down? Not great, because it was only in the table read.
I did not reread the table read for this. I just read the shooting draft and candy bag alts. Wow I forgot about that. Yeah I remembered it so clearly because you know after the table reads John and I would stay after and we would give our notes and we were like you know record scratch on the old Brian hits on Pam. Yeah, Brian's not touching her face or her hair. No, mm-mm, mm-mm. What they ended up doing is they kind of flipped it.
So now she has this weird kind of confession to Brian that she gets out, but he doesn't take the ball and run with it. He doesn't hit on her as a result. And then she switches gears and talks about the promos. And then she storms out because she feels like he didn't protect her as a friend, because she felt betrayed, not because he hit on her.
Right, it's a betrayal of friendship. These were her good friends. I mean, they would have dinner with him and his wife. She trusted him. Yes, and I get it. I mean, all this time, he's been hiding this information. He's been putting this job ahead of their friendship, and he didn't want to be like, hey, warning.
Yeah, don't go to the stairwell. Never have all of those conversations in the stairwell. We're filming them. Exactly. I know. And now also the fact that these promos have come out, you didn't want to take some initiative and be like, hey, you might be wondering. Here's the deal. Yeah. So that's how that all went down. But I will tell you this, unlike some of our other days where we were really finding the storyline in the moment, this was set and ready to go for when we shot.
And it was my favorite day of shooting with Chris Diamantopoulos. It was just, he is such a beautiful actor. And this was my favorite day. And I got them all to myself. It was a two person scene. Two person scenes are so fun because you really get to play. That's how I felt about my scenes with Oscar.
You have a real partner. Yes, and the way this was set up, it really just felt like this private moment and I loved it. Let's go check in over at Afflead because Jim and Daryl and Ryan are now in the middle of reading Ryan's screenplay. And you know Jim is trying to wrap this up. He's like, you know what, maybe we should finish the rest of this later because this is a big script. And Ryan's like, no, no, no. Let's keep reading. Also, I'm going to need you to get the rights
to Darth Vader. Yeah, I felt like Jim's obvious disdain for this screenplay and for any of Ryan Howard's ideas made him a very, very bad agent. Yeah. The whole point of being an agent is to blow smoke up people's asses. I mean, this is like agent and thing number, is to make your client feel like the most talented, beautiful, wonderful idea person, right? Like that's it. Like whatever ridiculous thing you say, they're like, oh yeah, yeah, oh, 100%, I'm right on it. Like they should be a yes man.
100%, they're your hype, they're your main heist man. You know what I mean? And I just felt like Jim's disdain was so obvious. I actually, I really liked it, how Craig was playing Darryl. It was really funny to me because I felt like Darryl was clearly uncomfortable, but he was also going along with it in a way that was more believable.
He was like, this probably will never get made. Yeah, but I'm going to hear this guy out. Yeah. Well, one of the things we asked Ryan was if he had any observations from his time on set. And here is what he had to say. I mean, really and truthfully, I think the biggest observation for me was was just Seeing you guys as the actors in your niche you know, I was always so used to people seeing me in my comfort zone, you know playing baseball and
Being able to watch other people like in their comfort zone and their niche of what they do I always think it's very, very cool and very exciting to be able to do. So, I mean, my biggest observation was just kind of watching and how good, how fast, how professional everybody was and just how much fun everybody got to have with the show. I'm like, honestly, I don't know how, you know, you guys make it through half of the takes with just all the
funny stuff. You really got to kind of keep it together. But I think that was one of the biggest things was just the professionalism that everybody had. And the food, the food behind the scenes, I don't know what it is, but you guys somehow, y'all might have, I mean, I guess obviously having a show like The Office, I mean, you get hooked up with some pretty good food, production food back there, so the food was really, really good as well, so loved that.
We did have good food. It's the one thing my dad said when he left the set. So many people comment on it. Well, finally, we had to ask Ryan Howard what it was like having his name as a character's name on the office. Actually it's been really, really cool. It's funny because I would go to places, whether I'm going to get coffee or just some other
stores or things of that sort. And some people are able to kind of tie it back together. But even more importantly, it's like some people would able to kind of tie it back together but even more importantly it's like some people would look at me and they're like man you look familiar and I would say oh yeah you know I get that every once and again it's like you know hey I know what it is you're in the office and it's like oh yeah yeah it's like some people may have known me more from the office than actually as a baseball player. So that was always something that I would, you know, get a
good laugh at and must have tried to do something right. So to be able to have that. So I think it's pretty cool that people could recognize me from the office and more so than that from baseball. But yeah, again, loved loved my time there. And just want to thank you guys for this opportunity to be able to hop on and be a part of the podcast. And I wish you guys the best of luck and look to hear from you guys in the future.
Amazing. Such a nice guy. I know. Thank you so much, Ryan, for being on the podcast. Yes, thank you for answering my DM. I know. So generous of you. Now we're going to find out that Esther actually
really likes Dwight. She comes up to him and Clark and says, listen, I think my father's planning a scheme in which he's going to put more miles on the tractor while pocketing the profit behind Dwight's back. She says you need to go ask him for a deal based on miles. Yeah. She said right now you're dividing it by days. But he's planning to rent it out to a neighboring farm on the weekends. And Dwight looks at her and says, wait, you'd be OK if I don't buy this tractor?
And she's like, what, did you just think I was tractor bait? Yeah. We got a soap box about this scene. It is from Laugh A in Minnesota. I loved the soapbox and I'm so glad they wrote in. Well, here's what they said. Ladies, I have been waiting for this question since you have started the podcast.
I even had a reminder in my phone every week to check when I could submit a question for this. That is commitment. When Esther tells Dwight that her father plans to rent out the tractor to the Vendor Kirk brothers on the weekends, she says that they will have the tractor for the same amount of work days, but that her father will be putting on 10 times the miles. In farming equipment, you do not record the miles, but rather the hours something is in operation. This is because tractors do more than just drive.
That's right. They often have hydraulic lifts and power going to a secondary machine that can be operational while the tractor is standing still. It killed me when Esther said, "'Miles, I knew that any good farmer would know that you gotta watch the hours on an engine.'" Mm-hmm.
Good catch. I loved that catch. And I just appreciate you setting that timer on your phone. I know, all this time. I would not have known this. Angela, you knew this. I did know this.
You know, I'd sort of forgotten it. So I think when I watched the episode, it didn't register to me for a second, but as soon as I read the soap box, I was like, oh my God, yes. Yeah. Yes. All right, I am gonna now move us to what might be one of my favorite scenes of the whole series. I mean, it is one of my favorite scenes. I'm almost declaring it my favorite scene. Well, that's high praise. It was definitely one of my favorite scenes to be a part of in the whole series.
I'm not the only person who loved this scene. Jen Solotta also talked about it. Let's hear what she had to say. Oh, I remember how much fun it was to shoot the scene where Angela and Oscar called the senator. You guys were killing it from the jump, and I remember laughing throughout that entire scene, and I'm sure I ruined a bunch of takes.
I remember once we felt like we had it. we played even more with kind of keeping those feelings inside of like the horrible things that you're actually saying and just kind of getting it out. Like you're just making a phone call and then being able to pop it a little bit once you and what you have to say. And then Angela, you just like collapse on the desk. I just love that.
I just thought that was such a fun scene. Angela, we also got a fan question from Ryan S. in Massachusetts. I would love to know the answer to this question. Ryan said, the scene where Oscar and Angela left that voicemail is one of the funniest in the series, in my opinion, also in my opinion, Ryan. How many times did Oscar and Angela break filming this scene?
Well, thank you guys all so much. I just loved, loved doing the scene with Oscar. And Ryan, to answer your question, we did not break once. That is so impressive. Yeah, I reached out to Dave Rogers and I said, Dave, how many takes did we do of this scene? What do you have that you can share with me? He sent me 14 minutes every single take we did.
Oh my gosh. Oscar and I were so excited to do this scene. We wanted to crush it and we were just like focused and you can hear Jen Salata cracking up. She's in the room next to us. She's in Andy's office and she would run in after each take and we did pretty much get it and like the second take she was like I mean that's great and then she was like do you guys want to play around and the scene was a little bit longer but we also got to play around and I thought I would share with you all one of the extended versions of the scene. Great!
Hi honey! Hi sweetheart! It's Angela and Oscar and we just have a quick couple of things for you. The documentary is going to air soon and in the promos you look great. You look so handsome, so presidential. Oh very much so, absolutely. Yes. I get the sense that you're going to be outed as being gay. And I cheated on you with Dwight and it looks like they filmed it. That is on me. Here's Oscar. Hey I was caught on camera saying that I thought your hair was too thin and I was in a mood when I said that I really don't believe it. If anything, I think my hair is too thick. Yes, it is so thick.
God, gross. Listen, Pam says it's probably likely they caught you kissing Oscar on film. And I also hired someone to kill Oscar. I was in a mood. She was in a mood. Yeah. So I think that's everything. I think we're good. Okay. Love you.
Bye. Bye. Hang it up. Oh my gosh, amazing. I love the part when Oscar was like, they got me on camera saying your hair is thin. Yeah, these are his confessions. I was in a mood. If anything, my hair is too thick. And then Angela also adds, I also hired someone to kill Oscar. And they got that.
Yes. So we got to play around a little bit. I loved the take they used for the actual episode, but I thought it would be fun to share with you this extended scene. I have to say my favorite part of this whole scene is how you lead with how great the senator looks. We saw some promos. First of all, you look amazing. Very presidential. Yeah, you're going to butter him up.
Yeah. And then horrible news is about to be delivered. All horrible news. Well, we need to check back in on Andy, because he's really starting to spiral. He's getting way too into the comments section. He's now posted a video of himself playing the banjo. He's really excited, because he's getting a lot of positive comments. But then some negative ones start trickling in.
First from Texas Poon Tappa, which we find out is Nellie. Yes. She's making him crazy in the comment section and he has no idea it's the person three deaths away. It's such wonderful comeuppance for her, isn't it? Yes. So you know, Jen sent us in an audio clip where she shares what might have influenced the storyline
of Andy having this online feud. You gotta hear it. So I'm not sure that this will be worthy of inclusion because I really can't remember some very key details. However, I remember feeling very passionately about some tiny detail in The Office, and I think it had played out over a couple of episodes. And I also remember that we would look at office tally comments.
And somehow after a number of debates where I was strongly on one side of something, I saw a comment on office tally after an episode of a fan just taking the opposite point of view like really strong. And again, it was a tiny little thing, but I thought, oh, the fans are even disagreeing with me now. So yeah, I don't know. Maybe I'll just kind of back down a little bit here. And then I remember finding out like a year later that one of the writers did a fake name and was pretending to be a fan from office tally and debating me through the comments section. So I'm not sure that that had anything to do
to inspire the Nellie, Andy story in this episode, but I found it very funny that you never know who was commenting and who you were disagreeing with. Just wanted to share that, bye. Oh my gosh, isn't that so funny? So funny. I want to know who the other writer was. I kind of do too. Wow.
Now I've heard of actors creating fake accounts to defend themselves in comics. Oh gosh. But I've not ever heard of someone, I guess this would be like a type of trolling, right? Like- A little bit. Is that what trolling is? It's kind of like trying to get your goat, right?
Yeah. Trying to get your goat, is that it? Or trolling? Goating someone? Yes to trolling, no to goating. What? What does get your goat mean? Like you get someone riled up.
Yeah, I think I've heard that. I wonder where that expression comes from. I don't know. goats can be feisty. I know that. So you're gonna get their feistiness going. I'm sure it's wrong. I'm sure I've got it wrong. I feels right. Um, says it's wrong. Well, we'll we'll see. Will you Google it real quick? What does get your goat mean? It's right. It's to make you annoyed or angry. Hold on, hold on. Suck it, Sam.
Suck it. You said goating. Right, to goat someone. Look up to goat someone. Okay, no, here's like, I think, yeah, I know to goat someone, like into an argument. Is it goad or goat? G-O-A-T, you're goating.
But are you goating someone or goating someone? I said goATing. The sentence example is, when I park in her space it really gets her GOAT. Yeah, it gets her GOAT. Yeah. But then what's GOATing? GOATing is to provoke or annoy someone. Alright. It's just, it GOATed him. Titted or didded. Okay, is that what you meant by goating? Yes! Okay, I thought you meant G-O-A-T-I-G. No, but goating is with a D. Yes, yes, not goating. You're not goating someone.
Yes. You're goating. Okay, okay. Or you're getting their goat. Okay, wait, wait. You, if you get their goat, it's G-O-A-T. Yes. But if you're goating someone, you're goating.
Goating. You know what? I got it half right. I'll take half answers here. Yeah. I like it. I'll accept it. Watch yourself, counselor.
Thank you. OK, well, listen. When I saw that Nellie screen name that she was using to goad Andy was Texas Poontappa, I was like, what did standards and practices have to say about this? What about Chobblegoppler? I know, all of it.
What about 50 Shades of Grey, the opening? So I asked Steve Burgess and he looked in his notes and he said, okay, they had no notes on the 50 Shades of Grey cold open. No notes. Okay. There was a note on the Danish promo. It needed to be accurate. What? Um, Steve Burr just said, note accurate, not perfect.
So I guess that was considered accurate. Oh gosh. They needed to make sure that any email addresses that we saw were fictional. Finally, standards of practices had some concerns about the screen name, You Suck My Nuts, but we got away with it. He said we even had to shoot an alt, but they let us use the original.
I'm telling you, they got way more lax. They liked Steve. They must have. Poor Randy Cordray would have gotten as previously stated email. Well, Pam is now watching some old footage of her and Jim. They're standing outside the office building. They're sharing headphones and listening
to a song on Jim's iPod. This is early Jim and Pam. It is. She has a talking head where she says, oh, I hope they got sound on everything. I'd actually love a DVD of that moment. She then types the word in Danish that's being used to describe her and Jim. It means lovers. And she smiles. Mm-hmm. Now, there would have been an extra beat here. It got cut out.
Mm-hmm. But we shot it. A delivery person was gonna bring some flowers into the office. Yeah, I remember us filming this. I do too. Well, everyone assumes that the flowers are for Phyllis. Yes, so they're delivered to Erin, and Phyllis kind of like perks up,
and Meredith is like, maybe they're for me, and Angela even pops her head around. Yeah, and Erin reads the card and says they're for Pam and then she says oh Jim wrote a card. And Pam's face just lights up. Erin reads quote, Pam I'm really sorry. Oh and then Erin continues, hope you're okay, Brian. And then Erin says, Pam, they accidentally spelled Jim's name Brian. Man, what a day, she says. I know. Well, this was another one of those scenes
after we read it at the table read. We were like, Brian cannot send Pam flowers. They kind of agreed, okay, fine, he won't hit on Pam at their meeting, but they wanted to keep this possibility of Brian in the picture. The producers and network? Yeah. But by the time we got to when this episode was going to air, they had decided that Pam walking out on Brian was going to be the goodbye to Brian.
That's it. That there was going to be no coming back from it. And so they ultimately ended up cutting this scene cause it sort of then reopens the door. I agree with that. Yeah. So instead this episode is gonna end with Dwight riding his new tractor down the street
with Esther by his side. Yeah. Traffic's piling up behind him and they're honking but Dwight and Esther don't care. They're just so happy. Listen everyone, that is Rain really driving that tractor. Steve Burgess said that Rain had to practice along with Nora next to him. They did their practice on Satticoi Street right in front of our stages but when we shot this they were out on Burbank Boulevard during magic hour, which is that beautiful sunset hour. And that's how we end the episode.
Well, I really loved rewatching this episode. We are in a little phase of episodes right now where they're kind of picking up. I'm really delighted by them. I've already watched Stare Maggeton, which is next week's episode. It is so good as well. Well, a big thank you to Dave Rogers for getting all of those extra takes of the Angeline Oscar scene for me and to Jen Salata for sending in audio clips. Jen is currently directing episodes of Abbott Elementary and Cobra Kai and it's actually the final season of Cobra Kai. Jen's last episode airs in November so you guys you have to check it out. And also I want to say
thank you again to Nora Kirkpatrick for sharing about shooting this episode and to Ryan Howard. Thank you for sending in those audio clips. Yeah. And as always Steve Burgess and all of you for sending in your questions and comments. We'll see you next week. We'll see you next week and thank you so much to Odyssey! We love our new recording studio! It's pretty sweet! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies! Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins, our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco.
Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leo Reese-Dennis. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.